[Music]
so
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
it's back big time the coronavirus
now thousands of people are reportedly
catching it
every day 149
in britain are on ventilators already
are we headed back to march are we
headed back to
general lockdown can we survive
if we do and what about all the people
who are dying
because they can't or won't go into
hospital
because of the fear and loathing
of the coronavirus me i'm being alert
because
there's thousands of them may be
shooting over my head we'll be
talking this evening about whether or
not
we are headed back to those dark days
and if we should go back to those
dark days and clickety click
66 this is episode 66
of officially the biggest show of its
kind
on the planet one million
people watched or listened to last
week's mother of all talk shows i'm
inferring the
300 000 listeners seems reasonable on fm
am
and online but i can prove that more
than 700 000 people
watched this show last week if you
are one of the watchers share
please right now with all of your
friends and contacts
because this is going to be really the
mother
of all talk shows the open university
of the airwaves there are no tuition
fees
and you are encouraged to speak back to
the teacher
a radio show with pictures what's not to
love
fasten your seat belts it's the mother
of all talk shows
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get
for
[Music]
george free this
is radio sputnik
can you imagine episode 66
of a radio show with pictures mounted
on a shoestring which only happened
because of my cockamania dismissal
by a local radio station in london
now has an audience of one million
people
across the globe more than 700
000 of them in black and white in print
on facebook on youtube on twitter
and on instagram and on
twitch this is a phenomenon
this is truly a global university and
i'm
honored that you are trusting me as your
professor
and in return i promise that we will
deal
continue to deal with the subjects that
nobody else
deals with and in a way that no one else
ever will you're all paying the bbc
if you've got a television that is you
go to prison
if you don't or you're paying through
advertising
if you're only watching commercial
television
thanks to rt and sputnik you're not
paying
for this at all although we'll be
starting next month a midweek
mother of all talk shows that you will
have to pay one dollar
or whatever the sterling equivalent is
next month
probably 75 or 76 pence
and that will be the mother of all talk
shows
truly unleashed unplugged
not that we're censored in any way here
but we will be i don't know more zany
more edgy and we'll deal with the very
very sharpest of issues so if you're one
of those watching please
i'll urge you now please share it with
everyone because i quite like it up here
on this cloud as you've probably already
inferred now the coronavirus
pandemic not only isn't going away
it's coming back it's coming back in a
serious
way now that doesn't mean that the
death toll that we experienced at one
stage in britain though we
deliberately concealed it we covered it
up
or we were losing 1 000 people
a day for a period in britain
now we're not and despite the massive
spike in cases doubling every week
we will not necessarily go back to that
level
of death though but we might what if we
do
what's going to happen in the economy
if we plunge back into
general lockdown will we even be
allowed to go to work
you know my view as the apocryphal
irishman
said when asked directions to dublin
he said i wouldn't have started from
here well i wouldn't
i told you right from the beginning what
we should have been doing
and how long we should have been doing
it and the government
did very differently we locked down too
late we lifted the lock down too early
we did not test and track and trace
we force people back to work
in unsafe conditions but our economy
fell by 20
in one quarter the biggest single fall
since the british economy existed
that fall cannot be afforded again
so what are we going to do now everybody
knows
about the chaos in testing at least
everyone
on this side of the atlantic knows that
our government
i cannot be trusted to go out for a loaf
never mind to safeguard the national
health service
and the public health of 65 million
people you wouldn't trust them to go
out to the shops for you if you were in
any doubt
about that then you haven't read the
excerpts
of diary of an mp's wife which
perfectly sums up the caliber
of the british political class today
this tome this diary
is serialized everywhere i'm reading
about it everywhere i
turn it's written by the
non-descript wife of an entirely
nondescript member of parliament who was
an entirely nondescript
minister briefly in david cameron's
government
his name is hugo swire i forget his
wife's name
her book spells out the
banality the utter
non-descriptness of the people
running our country it can be summed up
by her relaying not denied by david
cameron
that as he took her for a walk with her
husband
in the gardens of checkers the country
home of the prime minister
the eaton and oxford educated prime
minister
of great britain said to his friend's
wife
i'd like to take you in those bushes
and give you one
boris johnson at a number 10
downing street dinner complete with
candelabra
and white linen and silver spoons
shouted across the table at the
aforementioned
shugo swire then a minister in the
british
foreign office god help us hey
hugo did you shag jerry hall
that's the kind of people running our
country that's the kind of people who
are running it
under david cameron he's the kind of
people that are running it
under boris johnson they all went to the
same school
they all went to the same university
they have the same
cultural level which is on ground level
if not on basement level they all talk
to women like that
they all care only
about being in power as
another ex-foreign office minister
george walden
says in the papers today these people
come from such a bubble
such a tiny sliver of the british
society that they literally have no idea
which is why they thought brexit would
never pass they actually have no
idea what life looks like sounds like
is like in the country
as a whole they live their lives
from school through university and
into the professions on a cloud
but it is a cloud that is about to
open and britain is about to face
economic and political
challenges which have not been matched
since the summer of 1940
when our brave pilots together with our
commonwealth and other allied pilots in
the battle
of britain saved this country from
fascist
invasion and
being subsumed in the third reich
of adult hitler we have not faced
a crisis like that
until now it's not that
the coronavirus can be necessarily
compared to hitler
uh but it could be if the
pandemic were to go up several
gears which it could do if the economy
were to collapse
by another 20 percent
in this coming quarter
then the threat to our national life our
livelihood
and the well-being of our people
uh would be existential the briton that
would come out the other end of that if
there is a coming out
at the other end of that would be
almost unthinkable there could be a
collapse of social peace in this country
there could be a revolution
in this country probably not a good
revolution
about the first casualty of it will
undoubtedly be boris johnson
who is posted missing in dispatches he
is simply not on top
of his brief neither of the economy
nor of the public health situation in
fact
he personally has made it far worse
his government handing out a hundred
billion pounds or more
in public money to private companies who
have utterly failed
to carry out the projects for which they
were paid
have put us in this potential disaster
now where nobody can get a test
let alone be tested and tracked and
traced
we cannot gather in our homes
in more than six but we can sit in a pub
with 600 but only till 10 o'clock
we are paid to eat out just
two weeks ago if that eat out to help
out
which may well have accelerated the
spread
again of this virus they're even letting
people
into rugby games but not football ones
limited crowds but crowds nonetheless
none of this makes
any sense is my point none of this has
any logic and we have a crisis in
britain of numbers
of statistics nobody
knows whether they can believe the
statistics
nobody knows if they can believe the
scientists
now all of this is true of britain and
it's true with knobs on
in the united states of america where
anybody who believed
the government anybody who believed the
statistics
anybody who believed the science would
need their head examined
this is a state that spent the last four
years
talking about russia gate while their
country fell
apart and was set on fire
either by global warming in california
or by
rioters or arjun provocateur or a mix of
the both
in city to shining burning
city this is a country which is summed
up by the contest
joe biden versus donald trump
this is a country that doesn't actually
know
if this november's election
not only can be trusted but will not
lead to a civil war
will not lead to the crowd of mega
supporters
on the white house lawn being cut down
by the u.s
marines this catastrophe
of the neo-liberal blonde headed leader
scenario is facing both
of our countries britain and the united
states
and in the very very near future
london might be locked down next week i
might be forbidden by law to come to
work
don't worry about that we'll find a
solution if that were to
happen but the point i'm making is
these grave existential challenges
are taking place when both of our
countries are led by idiots
chamberlain was a disgrace an appeaser
he was a total miserable failure
but i suspect he was not an idiot
we are led by idiots
and there's no churchill waiting in the
wings
in either country think about that
i do i think about it all the time
and lastly we're going to be talking
about
cryptocurrency now
max kaiser is a big friend of mine so
you'd think i'd know
everything about cryptocurrency
but actually everything max ever told me
about
it went right over my head
maybe it did yours also although max is
on three times a week
and has a very big and loyal audience
i'll be talking to an old friend of mine
david lowe in glasgow
who runs a scottish bitcoin outfit we'll
talk about that
and he has the view that this could be
the answer
to a separatist scotland currency
dilemma
whereby the best they can hope for it
seems
is to be like panama using
american dollars whilst not controlling
them
and certainly not being able to print
all of that is coming up over the next
three hours we'll be talking to the
absolutely inimitable garland nixon
in just a few minutes about all things
americana
but i chose this poll
that's out now because i
could not believe my eyes last night
when the bbc led with the news
that a judge that i had never heard of
in the united states of america had
passed away at the age of 87.
in the midst of this economic and public
health crisis
in britain the bbc chose
to lead with the death of a woman
aged 87 who was a judge apparently
in a court in america
and so we're asking why was the death of
an american judge
a leading item on the bbc is it
a she was a liberal b
to damage trump or c
because we have become the 51st
state of the united states of america
it's all coming up get voting now on my
twitter feed
at george galloway and share share if
you're watching
right now please i like up here
as the host of the biggest show
on the planet i'll be right back
[Music]
i'm out on patrol with my hunting party
making sure that the people of britain
are staying in more than groups of
six i mean five i mean six less than
seven but more than five
that's six yes six look prime minister
over there
one two three four five
six oh bloody wrap scallions
breaking news expert analysis and
exclusive stories
all in one place
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
[Music]
record numbers on instagram and
even bigger numbers this week than there
were at this stage
7 20 london time last week so
we are headed back to that mountaintop
but i'm asking you please
if you're watching on facebook please
share it bring another
viewer won't you now the uh the poll is
going well uh too
uh why was the death of an american
judge a leading item on bbc
a she was a liberal 22 percent
b to damage trump 43 percent
c because we have become the 51st state
of the union 35
but in response on social media alex
says
because the bbc is obsessed with trump's
america
as does lewis he says the bbc have
always been obsessed
with all things american well let's see
i'm obsessed with garland nixon's take
on the u.s election and the ongoing
civil strife
in his country and he joins me now my
old colleague and friend
garland thank you very much indeed for
rejoining us we had a great conversation
a few weeks ago but things move on fast
the coronavirus is still
cutting a swathe through your people the
economic crisis
is even greater in your country than
mine but hey
we've both got a blond-headed idiot as a
leader
what could possibly go wrong well let me
start by correcting you that
um uh the uk or the england certainly
isn't the 51st state
because uh states have reciprocal
agreements for extradition here so
if that were the case if we were asking
you
to sign which which we shouldn't be then
certainly
um harry brown's killer would be headed
back so i don't know maybe you guys are
a colony you certainly don't have the
rights that another state would have
that's a very sobering uh observation
maybe i should amend that poll because
we have become a colony of our former
colony garland uh let's talk uh the
economy
first i'm fascinated by this
evictions crisis basically
your people have not been paying their
rent of their mortgage
the landlords and the mortgage holders
the mortgage
lenders have not been able to enforce
eviction on people until now now
the landlords and the mortgage lenders
have to do so because they are in hawk
to the banks with loans that they cannot
pay
and the banks are foreclosing on the
landlords and the landlords are
foreclosing
on the tenants and soon we'll be back in
the 1930s
in hooverville in intense cities
well you know the the difference is in
the 1930s there weren't on
military-grade arms spread all
throughout the nation like they are now
you know
there are now you know people had maybe
shot guns for and
guns for shooting varmints with on their
farms or now they've got uh
you know they've they've got uh uh
military-grade weapons everywhere and
what we're looking at is the dominoes
that are falling for a failed state
on one end uh the economic end of it you
have
the landlords that can't pay the banks
and the
the uh the properties go in default and
then of course needless to say the banks
start running into trouble but we
already know they're okay because the
government's going to bail them out
but on the other side we're looking at
probably i've heard
numbers 27 to 30 million families or
tenants being thrown out you add in the
kids you add in the extra people and you
probably have
what 13 14 of an entire
nation being homeless think about that
you cannot have
a a a civilized and structured society
if 12 or 13 of the people are wandering
aimlessly
around looking for food and things of
that nature and let me add this
people are not going to sit around and
be hungry and starve they will
take some kind of uh extra legal action
shall we say be
breaking into stores or whatever so
we're moving in a direction
we're not a failed state yet but if our
um if our leaders
and i use that word guardedly um if our
leaders do not take the correct action
which they seem incapable of both
politically
and morally now um we're looking at a
failed state
physically where you're going to have
you know it's going to look like a dawn
of the dead movie
yes but that's a very interesting point
because
largely not as much as we were led to
believe
but largely the 1930s depression was
endured
by the poor they had no weapons
they were beaten brow beaten but that's
not going to happen again
the people will not go quietly into that
good night
of hunger and homelessness
well the other part of it is this in the
1930s i believe about 60 percent
of or higher of the us were still living
in an agrarian society
so there were a lot of people that were
already poor one of the par a big part
of the new deal
was bringing modern amenities to some of
the rural areas
people bringing people water and
electricity and things of that nature
so they didn't have the things to miss
that they have now
and believe it or not if you talk to
older people in the black community
basically who talk about their parents
or grandparents during that time what
they'll say is most people in the black
community didn't even know there was a
depression because they were so poor
they were already living like there was
a depression in america because we had
apartheid
now what we have is people who are used
who are accustomed to
a fairly high standard of living and
they are not going to be happy
uh i suspect that as let me add this
and we're moving into winter if you've
ever been to chicago
or detroit you are not going to survive
in the open
during the winter time so we're looking
at not just this is not just a political
issue
this is not just a financial issue it's
going to become a
physical issue where we have to deal
with people who are on the streets
who are angry who are hungry and who are
armed in many
many instances and and i think we all
know that's not going to turn out well
wow now in the midst of all of this
we've got a contest between
a man who's barely alive standing for
the
democrats and a man who is barely sane
standing for the republicans and nobody
else
nobody else can even get on the ballot
not jesse ventura
who might be here and there not the
green party who
might be here or there but in any case
they're not in the debates
they're not in the national argument
what do people do when faced with two
cheeks of the same backside
like that especially a backside as well
unpre-possessing as this one
well and the sad part about it is you
know the
the uh the working class the working
poor the poor
uh have a discussion about what our
options are but
basically what we're looking at is we're
looking at a battle between
two factions of the ruling elite and
they've already both
won as far as the democratic party is
you know as far as their perspective of
beating trump
they say they want to beat trump but if
their main priority was to beat trump
really you're running joe biden and
you're going to convince me that your
top priority is to is to beat donald
trump
i don't think so they've already
accomplished their top priority
which was to beat bernie sanders that's
all that mattered if trump wins
they can still raise money they still
have their institution they still have
their power
and let's not forget that many of the
many
of the funders many of the powerful
people that support the democratic party
made it painfully clear that if job
excuse me that if uh bernie sanders were
the nominee that they were going to jump
over and vote for trump so the reality
is
the people who always win have already
won and they're playing us around the
edges to see
you know this is about when the
democratic party and the republican
party
is going after a million dollars of of
of
of of money for their campaigns which
one gets the 350 and which one gets 650.
who gets the bigger bite of the pie if
you've got the president if your party
has the presidency
you get the bigger pipe bite of the pie
it's the same donors
and they're playing the same game so
we're kind of caught at the bottom
therefore most americans i don't think
think there's gonna well i'll put it
like this
people who are paying attention do not
expect a dramatic change in the event
and i would even argue this
in the unlikely event that joe biden
wins because let's not forget
and this is critical joe biden has to
get through
at least one debate i don't know how joe
biden gets through a debate first of all
i don't know how he gets through the
average day
but to get through a debate i don't see
that happening
and of course his running mate is uh is
uh now describing the ticket as
harris biden rather than biden harris
well you know and i think she's probably
of the
of that entire group over there she's
probably the most honest one i don't
think anyone believes that joe biden is
competent at this point to run
you know a fast food restaurant much
less uh much less
um the united states of america the fact
of the matter is
that in my opinion they are exactly the
same
she's a person with no history of you
know running of being a governor of
running
any anything major she was an ag yes but
that's a different animal but the fact
of the matter is this
both of those people are conduits for
power i don't think anyone who
understands politics looks at
them and thinks that they have an agenda
that's going to be enacted over the next
four to eight years there is an agenda
that will be enacted
through them they are a conduit for the
people who want to get some things done
so
biden harris whatever call it whatever
you want to
but it's going to be the same
neo-liberal neo-conservative
policies that gave us trump and most
likely
if they win it we'll get a worse trump
next time
will they win at this point i'm going to
say no
simply because i'm thinking you know
when it comes down
to it i'm looking at the debates and i
say i i just think joe biden crashes and
burns
in the debates unless i'm wrong unless a
lot of people are wrong
this guy is not um cognitively competent
to stand up against donald trump and
let's not forget
uh when he went against bernie sanders
bernie sanders wouldn't take a bite out
of his hide
bernie sanders kept you know calling off
the dogs if
and when he stumbles in a debate against
uh donald trump donald trump will tear
him limb from limb i think we already
know
that donald trump loves to get down in
the dirt
and and attack you and fight in the mud
joe biden
i just don't think he's going to be
capable there was a time in his life
when he was
this ain't it and after the debate i
think there's gonna be an entirely
different conversation about this
if he's not wise enough and i'm gonna
say this if the democrats aren't smart
enough
to back out of the debate they'd be far
better off to take the heat for not
going to debate than they would to put
this guy out there and have him
you know do a mushroom cloud uh right in
front of the entire world
uh talking of mushroom clouds i'll tell
you what is keeping me awake
now at nights the intensification
of the trump administration's war of
wars
and war of sanction and trade
measures escalating
on the china front to the uh point of
conflict yeah it is you might think that
alarmist but this week
china was flying over taiwan
firing missiles and bombs over taiwan
into the sea because the united states
had broken
decades of policy
by breaking the one china policy by
sending
high-level officials to meetings in
taiwan that were absolutely determined
as a provocation to china and i'm
beginning to
worry that china's running out of
patience with all of this
tick tock tick tock tick tock and trump
might regard a war with china a limited
war with china
he would hope might be an election
winner for him
yeah and you are you know you are wise
in your concern here
and think about this you know for many
years um
a lot of developed nations have talked
about pakistan and said if the pakistani
government were eventually to fall there
are a lot of you know very nefarious
groups
behind uh you know in the shadows that a
lot of you know responsible countries
would have to go in and secure their
nukes right
well that's kind of us right now the
united states government
one could argue has fallen to some
extremist
uh you know extremist neoconservative
and and neoliberal
uh groups and we got nukes we are a very
dangerous country right now a country
that is basically falling apart
we have a government that is pretending
like everything's okay they're walking
around
again we're talking about upwards of 13
of the entire nation facing uh
homelessness
we're talking about hunger people people
you can go on tv here in america and you
can see people
who are going from uh a food bank to
food bank each day
just to get something to eat america's
turning into a third world country
but a third world country with nukes and
it is
we are very very dangerous uh a
situation
and i'll add this you know it was
projected that somewhere around 2030
that china's uh economy would pass the
us
as the number one uh the number one
economy
in the world right but if you look at
what's happening now our response to the
pandemic has pretty much wiped out our
economy you can change
2030 to i don't know i'm thinking 2021
because there's it seems to be getting
healthier
and our economy is to say it's in the
toilet would be
uh you know would be given at the
benefit of the doubt you can't have a
decent economy
when you don't even have a government
capable of of
of putting on an election in what is
ostensibly a demo
you know a democratic republic colin
nixon
i'd say it was a pleasure it is a
pleasure to
see you again but it's also quite
chilling if you
get my drift thanks for joining us on
thank you of all talk shows there's an
american call right now
on that subject let's take it please
chris let's go to
michael in minneapolis go ahead michael
hey george how are you doing today
always a pleasure to hear you go ahead
all right well i was calling in i i want
a quick comment just
briefly on what you said about the green
party and it's even worse than you think
recently the democrats worked and got
the green party stricken
off the ballot in three states including
swing states
pennsylvania and wisconsin so you won't
even have the option of voting green in
those states
but what i'm calling about was to talk
about uh rb uh ruth bader
justice ruth bader ginsburg whom
obviously you know you said you are not
familiar with so i thought it was worth
uh
bringing up uh ruth greater ginsburg is
a very polarizing but
important figure she's essentially
the you know she was the vanguard of uh
gender discrimination law
in the united states so she she managed
to make a lot of
um a lot of a quality cases that
previously had
not applied to women um were
applied so you know the things like
women were able
now to sign a mortgage without a man
have a bank account without a male
cosigner have a job without being
discriminated against by gender
why is all that left to judges michael
you see here
uh we we don't even know the names of
our judges i could not name for you
well but one the julian assange's judge
i don't know the names of any judges in
britain
is it a healthy sign of your democracy
that these fundamentals that you have
described
can be attributed to a judge
um no but george i think i think what it
highlights is that the judiciary in the
united states is a fully political
entity
and the right wing of the united states
has been you know there's been a full
out war on women
you know at least as long as i've been
alive and and far longer
so the reason why people are so scared
is because the liberals were already in
a 5-4
minority on the supreme court and now
with
rbg gone and and justice roberts is is a
very
he's very conservative but in our right
wing america he's the
quote-unquote swing vote and he usually
goes along with
prior precedence um although he is very
right-wing whenever he has the
opportunity to be
so the fear is that with rbg gone you
get another conservative justice in
and all of a sudden they don't really
they don't need roberts
um they don't need roberts as much to
you know to sort of change the laws and
to you know and the
the right wing in the united states is
always always trying to take away
reproductive rights from women
that's been a consistent fight ever
since roe v wade
in the 70s and they're you know the dude
like the states
in uh in certain conservative states
they're always
passing legislation to try to restrict
abortion rights and respect
restrict other health care rights for
women but the reason why this is really
interesting in election year
is because in 2016 uh justice antonin
scalia died 237 days before election day
and uh obama nominated
garland to replace him and the
the republican senate said no we're not
going to have a hearing
and instead of pushing for it instead of
using his bully pulpit which he was
never willing to do
and really you know really forcing the
republicans to make this an issue
privately behind the scenes obama said
hey this
isn't so bad because it will help get
the base out to vote
so he used so they sort of used the
supreme court seat
as a way to hopefully uh motivate
democratic voters of course it had the
opposite effect
and what it did was actually galvanize
trump's base and here and you know and
here we are
so now we're in a situation where that
was 237 days before the election
uh when um when when anthony scalia died
now we're only 46 days before the
election i think when
rbg died and now the same republicans
who said
oh it's got to be up to the american
people we can't have
you know we can't do this during an
election year are saying
oh we need to confirm someone
immediately well
michael all that tells me michael is
that donald trump knows how to use the
bully pulpit
in a way that uh barack obama was not
ready to
thanks for the call garland nixon was
listening to
that uh garland i ask in a way the same
question to you
as i did to michael uh i don't know how
liberal this woman was from a personal
point of view
i'm not sure what is progressive about
abortion uh for example uh i know that
people are gonna have it not trying to
stop people having it
but i'm not sure why it's progressive uh
how liberal am i supposed to regard this
woman
and why is a judge that important
in your system if all these things
abortion
uh gay rights and so on are so important
why do why doesn't the american
government legislate for them
why do they rely on a here today gone
tomorrow
judge uh you make a good point because
in in
you know within the context of the
american system most of the things that
the
um that the supreme court rules on
generally the
uh our congress our legislative branch
can go back
and tweak it and they can fix it the way
they want to but unfortunately
they're not they're generally unable to
do this but here's the thing about the
the concept of uh women's rights or lgbt
rights you know i work on a lot of that
stuff and i mean in in the in the um
you know in the interest of of of of of
of openness i'm actually on the national
board of directors for the american
civil liberties union so we're always in
you know supreme court for one reason or
another
and what i've found is the lgbtq rights
and things of that nature those
rulings to be quite honest haven't
changed much even with some of these
conservative judges when it comes to the
social issues they haven't been
really that much different um in in a
way that would be markedly
you know far right what what i see in
american
um in our supreme court is they are
there for
corporate law they are there to make the
decisions when it comes to corporation
when it comes to the things about you
know
uh women reproductive rights etc
conservatives have
actually recently been very angry at
their picks because you know let's face
it they're all the neo-liberals
neoconservatives
so-called left so-called right when it
comes to the social justice issues and
the issues of lgbtq etc
they're not that far different they are
there though
to deal with corporate issues and to
transfer full power
to the corporate oligarchs and they are
really good at that
garland thanks and i really appreciate
you sticking around to
respond to that call from the united
states now another
storm that brewed this week
was the book burning and the threat
of banning and worse
to j k rowling who'd have thunk it
i did a short for rt on it take a look
it's psycho the lunatics have taken over
the asylum
60 years ago the great alfred hitchcock
made his seminal movie psycho
and the murderer in that movie
norman bates didn't just dress up in
women's clothes
he dressed up in the clothes of his dead
mother nobody called them a transphobe
nobody is burning dvds of the offending
article
but when jk rowling was reported to
have dressed her murderer in her latest
novel in a wig and a woman's coat
well all hell broke loose
the roof came down on top of her
50 000 people on twitter
liked a video of someone having bought
the book
setting fire to it so now we're into
book burning territory book
banning territory now we're in
to full scale repression of
intellectual work i don't need to labor
the point
of where this can all lead who started
the
book burning fad in the 20th century
although witch hunters of all kinds have
burned
books and other people's intellectual
work
for centuries think the witches of salem
and you'll see that they don't
necessarily stop
at burning the books rip jk rowling
was also trending i've got to say
when you find yourself wishing
death upon an author a novelist
because of a character she's drawn in
her fictional work
it's you who's deep into psychiatric
territory
not her now i've never read anything
from jk rowling
not even harry potter matter of fact i
don't really approve
of harry potter but i wouldn't seek
to ban it still less would i burn it
even less would i wish death upon
its author i will fight to the end
to defend the rights of people freely to
express themselves especially when
i don't agree with what it is they are
expressing that's supposed to be the
hallmark
of civilization is it not that's
supposed to be
the hallmark of democratic thinking
and yet the people who are burning j.k
rowling's books probably regard
themselves
as right on liberals hip progressives
jk rowling has never said or written
anything
transphobic at least not that i have
seen
transphobic means that you fear loathe
transgender people i myself
have had real life experience with a
transgender
person i used to shake his hand firmly
when he was living as a man
kissing his cheeks tenderly when he was
transitioning to a woman and then with
some relief
i will confess shaking his hand firmly
again when he transitioned back again
i'm ready to treat anybody how they want
to be
treated but i will not sign in my blood
that they are what they would like
themselves to be
a woman or a moon landing astronaut
i'm ready to call you captain commander
wing commander but i'm not ready to let
you go behind the controls
of the spaceship at least not until
you've had some proper
training and i'm not ready to
agree to someone who is
defining themselves as a woman
i don't know stopping over at my wife's
baby doll pajama sleepover party no
that's for real girls i'm not ready
to let them bath with my daughter
or get changed in a changing room with
my daughter
i'm not ready for them to muscle in
on her sporting activities beating her
to a pulp in a boxing ring or
by a mile in the athletics because
that's where her freedoms are being
denied and invaded the freedom of women
and girls to their own spaces their own
sports their own private lives
is every bit as valuable
important inalienable than the right of
someone to
identify as something that they are
not that doesn't make me transphobic
because i neither fear nor loathe
transgender
people or transvestite people or gay
people
or any people who act differently
to me let a thousand flowers bloom that
is my credo but don't
ask me to describe rose
as a daffodil because i simply
won't do it me i stand
with jk rowling have something to say
do you disagree with george then call us
now
and give us your view well it's just as
well moats has got its own money man now
david law an old friend of mine
haven't seen him for many years but the
man that masterminded the
takeover of celtic and its move from
well the old world into the new
i think he's got a new book out actually
about that we'll ask him about that
but it's just as well uh david lowe uh i
hope
he will agree uh to be our money man
because i've now got breaking news from
the bbc
hsbc moved ponzi scheme
millions despite warning this is from
panorama
hsbc that's one of the world's biggest
banks
allowed fraudsters to transfer
millions of dollars around the world
even after it had learned of their scam
leaked secret files show britain's
biggest bank
biggest bank moved the money through its
us business
to hsbc accounts in hong kong
in 2013 2014.
its role in the 80 million
dollar fraud is detailed in a leak of
documents
that have been called the fin sen
files david lowe welcome uh to the show
it's been some
well the best part of 20 years very uh
good to see you again uh
we you came on to talk about
cryptocurrency and we will
but have you got a response to this
leaked
bbc material well george i just
heard about it literally 10 minutes ago
when i was speaking to
your researcher so i don't have any
details of what's come out
vis-a-vis hsbc but i think we all know
money laundering
and banks has been going on for as long
as there has been money and there have
been banks
so it's just very infrequently that they
get caught in such a large way
but it is as old as the hills and i
can't say i'm that surprised
but details i do not have i cannot
comment beyond that
does cryptocurrency
[Music]
uh deepen that potential problem or
alleviate it when you have value when
you have money
and when you have greed there is always
uh
fraud again that's as old as the hills
uh traditionalists bankers governments
those that seek to
regulate us will always plow the furrow
that
cryptocurrency is uh as a means of
anonymously
and fraudulently transferring money
that's not the case it's a convenient
banner a convenient headline to use
but it's certainly uh not the case most
transactions
buy out significant margins still go
through the traditional banking system
and that's where all the fraud lies and
for all the theft lies quite frankly
so uh but but on the face of it i mean
neither of us
knows the criminal mind uh but
if i was a criminal i'd want to have my
money in cryptocurrency rather than in
uh in the bank of scotland and bars road
wouldn't you i suppose you could say
that if you wanted to transfer a lot of
money anonymously
uh you would maybe look at
cryptocurrency as a means of doing that
but cryptocurrencies are becoming more
and more regulated
and practitioners in the industry have
to be
verified by the traditional uh setups
the traditional governments
it's no longer in the wild west that it
was a mere five years ago
you can't really get involved in this
space uh
in a significant way without uh the
people you're dealing with knowing who
you are
uh where you live where you stay and you
have to provide documentation
so as each year goes by it is conforming
more and more with what we
were familiar with in terms of
regulation well let's go back to
first base um a
very good friend uh of max kaiser
who might be called the cryptocurrency
king he was certainly
one of the very first off the rank
on it and he's spoken to me about it so
many times but i've got to tell you
david
almost all of it went right over my head
why don't you give us
an idiot's guide to what cryptocurrency
is well cryptocurrency is just a series
of codes
that operate on what everybody is
familiar with i think called the
blockchain
which is a just a euphemistic term for a
distributed
ledger technology whereby the assets
which is basically the pieces of code
are owned by
the people that operate the the ledger
uh the distributed ledger
and they get paid or the phrase users
they mine and they get paid in bitcoin
which is the first
and the largest uh cryptocurrency for
performing that
task so a distributed ledger comes with
a distributed cost
and that cost goes to the the miners
that maintain in this instance
which i'm talking about the bit came the
bitter coin block chain
now so what what do they mean by mine
now i've always been puzzled by this
phrase i have uh some experience of
mining
uh but we're not talking about people uh
uh
down below uh with a pickaxe uh hacking
away a wall what do they mean by mining
they get paid in bitcoin
for performing a duty or a function that
helps to maintain
the integrity of the blockchain
the distributed ledger it's a means of
payment for performing a duty
if you want you to dig dig or drill or
mine
deeper and deeper you really have to
speak to a a technology professional but
it would go beyond the comprehension of
most of the listeners i i would suggest
yeah there's a danger of that
uh let's say uh let's say i get paid
tonight uh
in bitcoin what does that mean do do i
get a bit of a coin
or do i get an email saying you're now
the proud owner
of x uh as your payment for tonight's
show
and if so how do i spend it
well think of it just as like an online
banking account
if you wanted to get paid in bitcoin you
would have to
have what's called a wallet and the
person that was paying you
would send you a specified number of
bitcoins or it could be a fraction of a
bitcoin
one bitcoin is worth approximately uh
ten
or eleven thousand dollars at the moment
well it would definitely be a fraction
david definitely be a fraction
well maybe a big fraction i don't know
if it was half a bitcoin if it was five
thousand dollars for example
the person that was paying you would
send you half a bitcoin from their
wallet
to your wallet and you would look at
your wallet in the same way as you would
look at a
an online banking account and you would
see a credit
of half a bitcoin to your account and a
bitcoin is just like another currency
like a pound a dollar a euro
you could they transform that into
dollars to
for value or sterling or euros it just
goes from one wallet to another is the
answer to your question uh and you see
it as a balance in your wallet
but i couldn't spend it instantaneously
i couldn't spend it in
well i could spend it i think in your
place in glasgow
because you take bitcoins but i don't
know any other shops or restaurants
that would take my bitcoin well there's
over 5000 cryptocurrencies
bitcoin a is what you would call the
first
bitcoin is what you would call the
largest in terms of uh
market value the last time i looked it
had a market value
of about 200 billion dollars and that
represented two-thirds of the total
market capitalization of all the uh
cryptocurrencies put together
but what is happening with bitcoin
bitcoin is emerging more
a george is a store of value much the
same as gold as an alternative
uh investment an alternative store of
value in these troubled times
more and more people are becoming more
and more worried as you know the world
we live in the people that are running
the world we're living
the veracity and and the
integrity of the existing banking and
saving systems and stock markets
so for more and more people uh bitcoin
represents what you would call an
alternative
investment and that basically means
they're buying bitcoin because they
think it's going to go up in value
it's a store of value so that that's
really the primary role
that bitcoin is playing as
it evolves now tell us about your uh
yours
your uh mac bitcoin march but
that'd be the scott coin so i mean
you'll probably
like this i mean i i'm an investment
guys you know private equity investor
i was sitting watching a alistar darning
debate
without alex salmon in 2014
uh over the currency for scotland should
it be independent and whether
alex had uh a plan b
and of course i don't know if you
remember that debate i do yeah of course
never forget yeah well i'll use my own
language i thought
and i'm not being political in saying
that i thought darling sliced and diced
alex salmond because he didn't have a
plan b
and the most uh the most important thing
that an independent country must have
and wishes to pay its ways a currency
and i thought a well if scotland doesn't
have its own currency i think this whole
independence thing is pretty much a
waste of time
and in saying that i have to keep
emphasizing i'm being
apolitical and i'm also being very
logical
so i thought well they're going to lose
their
referendum currency is not at evolved
power so
what can you have you can have a
cryptocurrency a scottish cryptocurrency
so i looked about i found that
one already existed the guy that founded
that guy called derrick nisbet
it was a one-man band of a fashion and
and he wanted to sell it so i i bought
the ip
myself and a business partner uh and
paid for it in bitcoin i might add
uh at a fraction of the price that it's
at just now and then we wondered what we
were going to do with it
and we've had it ever since but it
caught the upswing
in value bitcoin they went pretty
ballistic
and all the other cryptocurrencies did
as well over the next few years
and scottcoin actually emerged is a
global top 100
cryptocurrency which is maintained
because it's worth 140 million dollars
now the 5 000 cryptos that i've already
referred to
it's in the top 100 so there's no little
sideshow george it's quite a big deal
so how does it how much does it cost me
to buy one of your
scott coins well roughly if you want to
express it in sterling time a terms
because we're
we're in we're in the in the uk one
scott coin
worth our approximately 12 pens at the
at the moment
and when you extrapolate that that's out
to the coins an issue that's where the
140 million dollar value comes
but one spot coin is worth approximately
at 12 pounds
well uh consider one sold uh david if
you'll sell me one
uh and i mean are you
projecting this into the
uh independence debate
uh and if so is it falling on stony
ground
well we have had a some discussions with
uh civil servants representing
the scottish government but i as you
know governments around the world just
now are preoccupied with
immediate priorities and accept and
recognize that
something as far out for uh as
cryptocurrencies is a bit
too much for uh the scottish government
to deal with just now
but certainly i think scott coyne has a
role to play in
either a devolved or an independent
scotland cryptocurrencies are here to
stay there they're only going one way
and
that's upwards as more and more people
understand how they work
remember george younger people are more
tech savvy than people of our age
yes well that wouldn't be hard in in my
case now you'll always be mr
celtic to me did i understand correctly
that you've got a book
about the takeover no i did bring out a
book at the time
but what's happening it's on its fifth
day reprint just now
because a sort of younger generation are
are looking back 25 years and
and increasingly asking you know who was
this guy mccann what was all this about
you know i
i can hardly believe it's it's more than
25 years ago i can't
believe it sorry i can i can't believe
it i
had no idea it was 25 years amazing yeah
yeah more than that in fact but uh so
it's getting reprinted and
there's interest in turning it into a
movie i have no idea who will play me
be a great movie what what's the book
called david well the book's called the
mccann
takeover uh but it was originally called
the rebels in paradise
and you can you can buy it on a amazon
or directly from the publisher
which is me fantastic david lowe
the new moats money man thanks very much
indeed
for joining us i better go to the news
i'm two minutes late
it's the eight o'clock news with jamie
lowe
curious about our curriculum have
something to say
then call us now to join the debate on
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
radio sputnik we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news clovid restrictions
in england will get tougher if rules are
not followed britain's health secretary
has warned
as the government introduces ten
thousand pound fines for people who fail
to self-isolate
matt hancock said the country was facing
a tipping point
if everyone follows the rules then we
can avoid a further national lockdown he
said
the prime minister boris johnson is
understood to be considering a ban on
households mixing
and reducing opening hours for pubs
asked if england could face another
national lockdown hancock said i don't
rule it out
i don't want to see it the move under
consideration by johnson could take the
form of a two-week mini lockdown in
england
being referred to as a circuit breaker
in an aim to stem a recent surge in
cases
on saturday a further four thousand four
hundred and twenty two new covered 19
cases
and 27 deaths were reported in the uk
visitors have flocked to blackpool
despite police warning against having a
last blast in the resort before tighter
restrictions come into force
people reported cues for attractions
heavy traffic and little social
distancing
and few people wearing masks indoors
lancashire will be subject to tighter
restrictions from tuesday
after significant increases in covert 19
cases but blackpool is exempt
police had said they were preparing for
large crowds over the weekend
singapore is distributing thousands of
devices that can track where a person
has been
and who they've interacted with the
small bluetooth device is meant for
those who do not own smartphones and
cannot use a contact tracing app that
was previously rolled out by the
singapore government while there are
some concerns over data protection
authorities say the token helps
vulnerable groups feel safer when out
and about
australia looks set to record its lowest
daily coronavirus increase for three
months with just 18 new cases reported
so far the state of victoria the
epicenter of the country's covert 19
outbreak recorded 14 new infections to
sunday morning down from 21
the day before new south wales and
queensland reported two cases each
the remaining states are yet to report
their figures but rarely record any new
cases
figures were last this low on june 23rd
victoria's premiere daniel andrews said
the numbers were caused for great
optimism
his state which has accounted for 75
percent of australia's 26
900 cases and 90 of its 849 deaths
have been on the lockdown since early
july melbourne the state capital has
been under tighter restrictions than any
other areas
including a curfew and stay-at-home
orders anti-lockdown protests in the
city have become a regular site
earlier today demonstrators gathered in
the central business district
saturday's protest center park saw
protesters being dispersed
by police on horseback just one in 10 of
the world's population is likely to be
protected against covid19 and the first
year of vaccine being made available
according to scientists
analysts of global manufacturing
capacity shows just 2 billion doses
could be made in 2021
even if vaccine was given the green
light by safety regulators at the start
of the year
but with seven of the nine prototype
vaccines in late stage clinical trials
requiring two doses
that's likely to be enough to immunize
only a little over 12 percent
of the 7.8 billion people who need it
u.s president donald trump has said he
will this week
nominate a woman to replace the late
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
escalating a political route over her
successor
ginsburg who was 87 died on friday just
under two months before the u.s
elections
trump's democratic rival joe biden
insists the decision on her replacement
should wait until after the vote
the ideological balance of the
nine-member court is crucial to its
rulings
on the most important issues in u.s law
trump has vowed to swear in ginsburg's
successor without delay
a move that's infuriated democrats who
fear republicans will vote to lock in a
decades-long conservative majority
on the country's highest court ginsburg
had also made her feelings clear in the
days before her death
my fervent wish is that i will not be
replaced until a new president is
installed she wrote in a statement to
her granddaughter
a package containing rice and poison
that was addressed to president donald
trump has been
intercepted before it reached the white
house the letter was discovered as a
screening facility for white house mail
earlier this week officials said
they said a substance found inside the
envelope was identified as ricin
a poison found naturally in castor beans
the trump administration is yet to
comment on the reports
airstrikes on a taliban base in
northeastern afghanistan have killed at
least a dozen civilians
the twin afghan strikes in conduct come
as the country's government and the
taliban hold talks to reach a peace
settlement
provincial officials at a taliban
spokesperson said at least 12 civilians
were killed
and more than 10 injured a defense
ministry spokesperson claimed that more
than 40 taliban fighters were also
killed in the strikes
the taliban however did not confirm
whether there were any casualties
amongst its fighters
and finally a football match was
disrupted by an unusual pitch invader
when an alpaca bounded onto the field
carlton athletics tie against ilkley
town in west yorkshire on saturday was
halted for 15 minutes when oscar the
alpaca
escaped from a nearby farm and joined
the action attempts were made to entice
it off the pitch with food before a farm
managed to shepherd it home
carlton is renowned in the league for
having alpacas nearby
ilkey manager simon armstrong said after
35 minutes it escaped came through the
entrance and proceeded to get on the
pitch the referee stopped the game
carlton athletics said farm animals had
been kept near the pitch for several
years
but it was the first time one had
managed to stop a match club chairman
john flynn said i don't know how he got
out there must be a little gap in the
barrier somewhere as we've seen some
chickens here as well
oscar alpaca is reportedly very
inquisitive and appeared to be enjoying
himself
running up and down the pitch a couple
of players even said
he should be the man of the match and
that's the latest here on sputnik news
i'm jamie luck
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now just to underscore david lowe's
point about this
cryptocurrency thing being a young
person's game
young jamie lowe who reads the news so
brilliantly
but who looks to me about 16 is himself
a bitcoin cryptocurrency king
he certainly makes more out of
cryptocurrencies than he does for
reading the news
for me let me assure you now on my poll
what was the uh why was the death of an
american judge
a leading item on bbc a she was a
liberal
21 b to damage trump
40 c because we have become
the 51st state of the union that's at 39
so either to damage trump or because we
are the 51st day or maybe
actually all three anyway you can vote
until
10 minutes to nine on my twitter feed
at george galloway now uh it was another
week of persecution veering between
uh tragedy and farce and back again to
tragedy in the old bayley this week in
the persecution
of julian assange pablo navarette has
made a cracking film
about this and he joins me now pablo
thank you
for joining us we'll talk about your
documentary in a minute uh but
how did the week go for julian
from my standpoint his defense team
is winning every argument out of the
park
question is does that matter
unfortunately it
probably might not matter and that and
that speaks to the absolute travesty
uh of the british judicial system and
specifically in relation
to the process around julian assange i
mean
uh there has been a litany of articles
now
showing uh the irregularities in how
this case has been processed from the
very beginning
uh even with you know with the kierstama
when he was head of cps
intervening with the swedish uh
prosecutors who wanted to speak to
julian initially over these
sexual assault allegations to the judges
presiding over the case them
links to conservative or in many in some
instances they're married to
former conservative defense ministers
links to the security services
but yes i think this i've heard the same
i've heard that the
uh the defense has been winning hands
down
uh and that this really should really
mean in any fair system of justice that
the judge would not allow the the u.s
expedition request and allow julian
assange to go
to the yes where he faces 175 years
in prison further prison for exposing
u.s war crimes
however this judge has a 95
i think a rate of extraditing people and
as i said the british justice system
has covered itself in in uh
you know in gloriously uh with this case
so let's wait and see
but it's been a good week i i i'd be uh
amazed uh she might be fooling us all
but
she has favored the americans
at every turn on every point from the
regime that julian is enduring
to the conduct of the case in court
the potential
offenses uh of uh of uh
distortion of the process abuse of
process
our legion now and uh they may all have
to be explored
in uh in an appeal uh which of course if
she finds
in favor of the u.s there will be and
maybe
a better judge maybe a judge that cares
more about justice will be found on the
appeal
court but she could be i suppose the
greatest
actress since garbo uh and uh
giving us all these uh um
dashed hopes uh only in order to
turn the tables that's a possibility
the defence team produced some pretty
spectacular witnesses in the week
including the legendary
18 nine-year-old daniel ellsberg
the man who leaked the pentagon papers
which changed the course of american
history political
and legal history who's still alive
and who was on
i think two o'clock in the morning his
time or three o'clock
in the morning at his time uh by video
link
to the court and he was unequivocal
wasn't he
yeah i mean not just daniel ellsberg but
he joins i mean a legend
such as daniel ellsberg has joined what
now is an increasing chorus
uh of a real journalist i'd say because
there are the
those that call themselves journalists
who have
uh really joined in the persecution who
have been kind of
almost to get the vanguard of the
smearing of julian assange of the
uh people journalists uh a notable
amount of them at the guardian newspaper
who have been
you know initially for benefiting from
all of this uh
courageous journalism that julian
assange uh has exposed and done
but now we're very much at the at the
vanguard of smearing him of setting the
ground for public opinion to not really
care sufficiently that a
a journalist is being uh a political
prisoner
in the uk but we have real journalists
like john pilger real journalists
like daniel ellsberg even real
journalists like mohamed el masi who
appears in my film someone who's just
been reporting the truth around this
case
very meticulously uh from the very
beginning and i think anyone
who reports honestly about the case um
will will report that this is a a
massive political persecution of a
journalist
for exposing war crimes and what the us
has been trying to do
is to send a very chilling message to
anyone almost like a mafia
almost like a mafia leaving at the the
dead the head of a dead horse in
someone's bed sort of saying
you know you mess with us and we will
destroy you and so
um i think that true journalists
know what's at stake tr real groups of
freedom for expression now
without what is at stake and i think in
as far as the truth can come out i think
public opinion
can maybe help turn this and put
political pressure
uh on on the british to to not acquiesce
in in becoming the 51st state of the us
as you
mentioned if the if we're not that
already uh yeah
um and of course peter hitchens uh a
right-wing conservative journalist
very powerfully coming out for julian
assange this week
and the wonderful court reporting from
the honorable craig murray
former british ambassador one does sense
a certain change
the issue is whether or not it's too
late now tell us about your
film pablo and how people can see it
so my film is a 35-minute short
documentary that
that follows julian's father john
shipton who's been cut
travelling to and from australia here to
visit julian to help
to be part of this global grassroots
campaign
to to to prevent julian from from from
essentially being killed in a u.s uh
prison
uh he's already suffered as we know um
as a
de facto prisoner in the ecuadorian
embassy given that the uk did not allow
him
fake passage to ecuador after he was
given political asylum in this film
uh just follows julian's father a number
of solidarity events in the uk but also
uh he tries to humanize uh the story of
a father essentially trying to save his
son's life
but it also tries to offer this other
side which is to
show this group of sort of very
dedicated small but
very dedicated grassroots activists who
have come rain or shine been outside del
mar prison
outside the ecuadorian embassy outside
the westminster magistrates court
who have been shunned ignored by the
media denigrated or laughter
and who know what's at stake they know
that this is one of the greatest
injustices of our time
so the film just tries to show both of
those sides
of a story in a 35 minute film and
you can see it it will be actually on
vimeo on demand as
of early this week we've done a number
of online screenings
we've done a screening in spanish and
french in brussels on monday
there will be other screenings in
different languages but it will be
available to stream on
on demand this week and it's called what
pablo
it's called no extradition um which is
which is a simple uh title and it's the
title that was on
the placards that i would see at belle
marsh
at the magistrates corps and it's uh it
basically encapsulates really what
what what the call is what the demand is
and what really should happen
if there was any justice with julian
assange i hope everyone watches at pablo
navarrete thanks for joining us on the
mother of
all talk shows on facebook tom says
sleepy joe will not turn up for his
debates with trump
they'll make an excuse for him and
michaela says
trump has nothing to worry about he has
walked
this and gareth says i never knew
garland nixon
he's great thanks for having him on
great indeed he
is and on twitter roger says you can't
pay
tax on cryptocurrency it's specifically
for
tax tax dodging payments anyway
you can't buy bonds with it it's a game
running alongside a real economy
nothing more than an elaborate paypal
jason though says only in a few places
is bitcoin
legal tender for tax i've been involved
for several years
it's here to stay says jason and it will
soon replace gold
as the chosen secure long-term
investment that's why i'm buying 12
pence worth of
scott coin instead of buying gold i'll
be back in 60 seconds
with that was the week
hello peach of express smoking
what is it you want oh you want an
ill-advised interview on the bbc
a cheese pizza extra immature and a
rural bailout
no we don't take taxpayers money yeah
but we do take contactless
would you like a scene for that mr
[Music]
princess
the giant labour party sailing clearance
is now on
hurry now as we've got zero interest in
our party
it's literally the lowest it's ever been
give up on the common man and safe today
that's right we're getting rid of all of
the corbynites
literally every single one being a
blairite has
never been more in style only available
at what should be the uk's biggest
political party
the new new labour party we're doing
this again
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
george galloway and the mother of all
talk shows
join us at the college of knowledge
where there are no tuition fees
now this is the spot where i look at the
seven days these seven days in history
which have changed the world or perhaps
just heavily influenced it
this is the week and to be honest it's
not been a particularly auspicious
or earth-shattering one but on this day
in 1970
the russian space probe luna 16
landed on the moon to collect samples
from its surface
we're going to look at the whole issue
of ufos and so on
uh in our moats extra uh when it starts
in
uh in october and we'll talk to this
man richard gage on the 911
issue also uh it was the first time luna
was the first time an unmanned probe has
been used to bring objects back to earth
from space in 1973
this week tennis champion billie jean
king remember her
beat bobby riggs in what was called the
battle of the
sexes after riggs challenged her to the
jewel
i remember that very well and it was
rather long
ago a day later on the 21st
of this month in 1922 president warren
g harding signed a joint resolution of
approval to establish a jewish homeland
in palestine and in 1936
the spanish fascist junta named
francisco franco to be generalissimo
and supreme commander and in 1949
chinese communist leaders proclaimed the
people's republic of
china that's pretty important for
goodness sake
this was the week in 1998 that president
bill clinton's testimony
about his relationship with a young
female assistant
was released to the united states public
the video of the american president's
embarrassing interview
in front of the grand jury was broadcast
on u.s networks during the examination
clinton was questioned
by prosecutors about the exact
nature of his affair with monica
lewinsky
and whether he had previously lied under
oath his defense against the accusations
relied on elaborate definitions
of certain words and i'm quoting
it depends on what the meaning of the
word is
is if is means is and never has been
that's one thing
if it means there is none that was a
completely
true statement he said
confused they were yes there are no
nouns and
unknown nouns and downright obfuscation
i did not have sex
sexual relations wouldn't that i did not
have sexual relations
with that woman did i tell you my monica
lewinsky story
in the run-up to the iraq war i was
forever saying on television and public
platforms
i'm in favor of a special relationship
with the united states of america
i just don't want the kind of special
relationship
that miss lewinsky had with president
clinton
with the junior partner always on their
knees etc etc
it was a zinger i mean it really
traveled people would laugh
people would applaud wildly but
one day tony blair asked me to stop
using it and as i was a labour mp at the
time and he was the leader
of the party and because i'm that kind
of guy
i gave him an assurance that i would
stop
using it because he argued it was really
demeaning
and degrading to the party and the
government and therefore the country
so i stopped using it i didn't use it
for months and then one day
at the london school of economics where
my grandson
who is working next door uh is going to
be studying quite soon no he's at sawas
the school of oriental and african
studies
very nearby anyway i was at the london
school of
economics and it was a huge meeting
against the oncoming war in iraq
it was packed to the guns hundreds and
hundreds of people there and for some
reason
i use that line again i just don't want
a special relationship like the one that
miss lewinsky had with president clinton
and i was vaguely aware of a kerfuffle
and someone
marching out and slamming the door and
the next questioner said that was rather
mean
mr galloway because not only is miss
lewinsky
a student at this school but she was
present
in the second front row uh when you just
said that and she's just stormed
angrily out the door so i'm sorry
miss lewinsky if you're watching where
was i
uh a few years before on this day
in 1986 prince charles heir to the
british throne
admitted on tv that he talks to his
plants
still does apparently doesn't everyone
talk to their plants
on september 22nd in 1980 war broke up
in what was to be a 10-year conflict
between iraq
and iran when iraq bombed several
iranian air
and military supply bases including
tehran's
international airport britain of course
was on the side of saddam hussein
in 1952 on september 23rd
the world famous film actor and director
charlie chaplin returned to england for
the first time
in 21 years he arrived with his wife
oona
daughter of playwright eugene o'neill
and their four children at southampton
on the queen elizabeth cruise liner
having been barred from returning to the
u.s
because of his political views they
eventually settled in switzerland
and went on to have four more children
god bless them all
imagine america banned charlie
chaplin i read his autobiography as
a very young man i must have been still
at school
it's a very profoundly impressive
book i must say also on the 23rd of this
month in 1957
u.s president dwight d eisenhower
ordered u.s troops to
support the integration of nine black
students
at little rock central high school in
arkansas
later famous for the obfuscator bill
clinton
this was the week in 1976 when the rogue
rhodesian government as was agreed to
introduce black majority rule to the
country
within two years but only after
the black majority in the country had to
wade through
oceans of their own and other people's
blood in order to force them to do so
a year later on a year later on
15 000 people attended steve biko's
funeral
in south africa he had been murdered by
prison officers and on the 25th of this
month
in 1983 38 prisoners escaped from the
mays
high security jail in the north of
ireland
and i actually know the man that
organized it
and finally on the 26th it was the day
in 1580 that francis drake completed
the circumnavigation of the world
sailing
into plymouth aboard the golden hind
although there are still people watching
this show who believe
he should have fallen over the edge
because of course the earth
is flat in 1969
the beatles released the abbey road
album
in this week and in 1984 britain and
china
finalized an agreement to end more than
150 years
of uk occupation in hong kong
and we're seeing the ramifications of
that to this day
well perhaps it was a bit more of a
significant seven days
than the people through the glass
imagined
that it would be now we'll take calls uh
next oh two oh seven seven nine eight
two
two five five is the number in the uk
and in the u.s it's zero zero one
seven five seven seven four four four
four
eight zero we've even got a caller
on the line it's john in glasgow on the
virus go ahead john
hi george how you doing sir good very
nice to hear from you
yep yep i'm just really born in with
regards to the actually work for the
glasgow city council okay okay and i'm
basically concerned just now you know
because they were dealing with
like a temporary accommodation and i
take
no interest in the safety of employees
who are going into
different different areas in different
houses
you know you mean there's not enough ppe
for example
sorry you mean there's not enough
personal protective equipment yeah
oh yeah i i uh exactly talk to
tightly there's actually none you know
nothing
what's the union saying about that john
well i think i must actually tear him to
be honest
he was obviously
oh my goodness it's eves in idaho up
next go ahead eves
hello george uh thank you for having me
uh i wanted uh to to tell you uh um
one thing about uh julian assange why i
feel a little bit
optimistic and also i would love to to
ask you a question about it but
my comment is that if i understood if i
understand it correctly
the prosecution tries to prove that
julian assange endangered the life of
some spy and thing like that and the
defense
tried to prove that it's political
now a few a few days ago i think
i heard that the prosecution the
american side
the justice department acknowledged
that assange was given
a proposal you know to give up his
source
uh in in exchange for pardon
and that for me is uh is devastating for
the prosecution because
how can you say that it's about saving
the life of your spy and things like
that and at the same time trying to get
some sauce
so i think that that is not going it's
not
going very well no they also uh the
justice department your justice
department uh
was also forced to acknowledge uh that
they have no evidence of
any person coming to any harm as a
result
of wikileaks's uh dumps because
wikileaks took uh quite extraordinary
care
uh to redraft names and identifying uh
characteristics
yes that's true so i think i think
basically
uh they don't have a very good case and
i feel
like uh england at the end would not
extradite him i'd be surprised if the
appeal court actually writes to them i
must say
i'm i'm almost certain that this level
uh of court that he's in now
uh will uh will extradite him but i
i cannot believe that the uh british
judiciary which is
um the last institution
in the country that i would say
has not been entirely corrupted
would agree to that extradition in these
circumstances
but we'll see go ahead yeah yeah yeah so
my question is though
america doesn't recognize the
international court of justice but my
question is
england they do they do
follow the international court of
justice recommendation
why the international court of justice
doesn't
uh tell england doesn't take the case
basically
well well uh because uh these cases
that he's being tried on uh cannot be
tried at the
international criminal court the united
states
refused to join uh the icc
uh in fact despite refusing to join it
it is currently literally threatening to
invade
the hague in the netherlands i'm not
making this up
they have a proposed bill the invasion
of the netherlands bill
in front of congress which they hope to
give them power to invade
the court in the hague if the corps
ever had the temerity to
prosecute any american citizen can you
believe that
yeah it's unbelievable and only a
country of course can refer a mata
uh to the icc not an individual
or any other entity only a state
anyway go ahead is that your question
eve thanks as always for the call
brian is in motherwell on the
virus let's hear if we get more sense
out of brian
than we did out of the last joker but
one brian go ahead
hello mr galloway hope you're out very
well thank you very much
um well what i was was i was reading the
newspaper
and during the week and i've discovered
an article
about van morrison neil noel gallagher
and ian brown from the stone roses right
three men that grew up
i grew up with my musical heroes and
some still my heroes i don't disown them
in any way
but i was very um you know if i haven't
might challenge the musical wasn't
international weeks
you know van massen was one of the
greatest white soul singers of all time
i don't know i've spent a lot of money
watching van morrison
yeah quite right and um but i'm very
angered
um at their comments this week um
don't no no none of these three men have
set foot in a university
they've got no medical background so
don't act as if they know more than the
scientists do
and when it comes they also don't have
to get on the bus brian
yeah they don't have to they don't have
to work in tesco
they don't have to work in the carpet
factory uh
they are living lives of ivory tower
luxury so uh coronavirus not quite as
fearsome for them as it is for your bus
driver
it certainly has not and i may be wrong
about anybody's welcome to correct me on
this
but my understanding is japan never
even shot down their economy but what
they did do but they ensured that all
that public war
face masks and according to what i've
read
they've had one twelfth of the deaths
that the uk had
and they didn't even enshrine their
economy something think think about that
for a minute
and all that coincides with the
scientific consensus
that face coverings reduce your risk of
catching corona virus by 80 percent
that's just what i've heard it's not 100
percent effective but
of course but
if you put it this way if every single
person
in the country wore a mask then the
transmission from person to person
uh through spit coming out of the
mouth would obviously be
heavily reduced that is i mean an idiot
can see that
and japan is 11 and gave an example of
and no no gallacher is somebody that has
surprised me in recent years
um like a working-class guy growing up
in a working class here in manchester i
i used to think he's bothered his
argument one band standing have a
rethink on that well
you know what his brother said i can't
swear on the on
rt but uh his brother had some choice uh
words to describe him let's just say
that his brother that we both thought
was the arrogant one
he's got a lot more sense than noel
gallacher
thanks very much brian uh for that call
uh what happened to john
has become a thing has become a question
uh rev says john on the phone while
being exercised by the priest
was that what it was i'm glad it was
only exercised by the priest
and paul says he's misses him on the
head with a saucepan
ali says what happened to the yelling
guy assange got him
ray says john got john got covered
live on the phone and alex says
john just got his phone bill that is
very very funny thank you very much
indeed kristen says how will this damage
trump
what is the what britain already dislike
him
this is the uh the poll question i'll
come to that
in a minute and on facebook mark says
can we expect the bankers
in the city of london alleged in the
recent report to have laundered money
for criminals around the world to be
held in belmar and extradited
to the united states to stand trial and
face
up to 20 years didn't think so
says mark ditto says george
uh now let me give you the poll numbers
because you've only got
10 minutes to vote why was the death of
an american judge a leading item
on bbc news a she was a liberal 21
b to damage trump 41
and c because we have become the 51st
state
of the union that's at 38
so 10 minutes to go on my twitter feed
let me take a quick break
[Music]
call me come and have a go if you think
you're hard enough
don't bring up a false name come on air
call me and let's have this mata out
[Applause]
[Music]
that's 2016's argument michael i'm no
longer arguing with you
about the merits of brexit i'm arguing
with you about democracy
about the right of the majority
to have their decision their vote
implemented
[Music]
i want a referendum let me put that in
capital letters
if you think this year of 2020
which is shaping up already to be an
honest
miserables for the snp if you think this
is your year
go ahead come on let's have it out
but no george it's not as simple as that
right have you seen the documentary
about cambridge analytica and people who
work there
have you looked at this i know nothing
about that i'm not interested in
precisely but i'm not
i'm not interested in them bruce because
it's all a red herring
just like russia gay was a red herring
do you only want to hear voices that
agree
with you because if you do you're not
clever enough to be at this
open university of the airwaves in fact
you need to go back to remedial
and learn something about what democracy
and freedom of speech actually mean
[Music]
[Applause]
george galloway and the mother of all
talk shows
join us at the college of knowledge
where there are no tuition fees
now duke says on youtube i got an email
from a nigerian prince
if i send a hundred quid i will get i
will get a million
bitcoin that is such a coincidence you
cause
that nigerian prince is forever
also writing to me and sam says on
youtube what garland said is true
americans can't even make ends meet
going from one
food pantry to the next way before covet
hit i volunteered
in one for a year i couldn't take the
heartbreak and the sad situation i
witnessed
a large number of people are concerned
about what happened to our earlier
caller
so if he would put people out of their
misery and tell us
whether he was struck down struck dumb
or just dumb i'd appreciate it
and john says most american young people
don't even know
who adolf hitler was or when the second
world war
took place how sad is that brian
is in glasgow let's hear from him go
ahead brian
hi george scotland tonight
well i hope you're not showing anybody
sir george
i'll be accused of it i'm sure it
depends if you're a celtic man or not
hey i'm a celtic man but i lived in
lockhall for many years and i'm not
really
as far as a celtic avengers fan
considered a true fan because
i will support rangers and as you know
true celtic rangers sub plans
never seem to support the other people
no no that's but that's actually
explaining that to the rest of the world
brian it's a yeah it's a
scottish thing go ahead yeah uh
well i was going to talk george about
two cases and i know i was another day
to your a
people's party a dissertation a the
julian assange case yeah and this
and the comparative analysis to that
american justice system
and how it treated uh mr epstein
yeah now people talk about the charge
you go
i see that charge as a criminal
act as far as the legal system of
america is concerned
how can a man be charged with soliciting
prostitution from a child now he
attempted the rape of a child
yeah first of all then he got an
18-month sentence where he was out every
day
yeah it was good he was going to work uh
in a chauffeur-driven limousine every
day
he only slept in the jail he was doing
more than that
i'm sure more than that i'm sure he was
yeah i saw the netflix
doc yeah and george i have to say
i'm amazed at the public as well here
because on the same part
julian assange's continued incarceration
is a criminal act i sent an email to
your
a on air saying that there's a pinochet
versus
court case remember yeah it was
dismissed now people seem to think it
was dismissed because of his age
it was dismissed technically by the set
up
by the british state and i would wonder
if you are a ex-ambassador friend mr
murray would know this
but his case was dismissed because i
used it in my own case
a in a civil case where he could not be
seen
to get justice because one of the three
judges overseeing his case
had a relationship as a chief executive
raising funds
for one of their signatories to his
arrest
human rights watch e-ray swanson
puliazar
as a philanthropic effort but
nonetheless he appointed himself to this
crucial case
then the prosecution got a anonymous
call to make them aware of this
discovery
and it was in that basis his case was
dismissed because he couldn't be seen
to get a fair trial now we come to
julian assange
you jr sanji is not a citizen of this
country he has
indulged in journalism journalism and
the american sense
is built into the constitution and so
you are watching the complete criminal
capture if it's always not always been
that way
of america and britain because i don't
understand
how the public haven't got it we are
being run by criminal's job well uh the
public
uh uh thanks for that brian the public
haven't got it because the
media has deliberately kept the truth
from the public uh mike is in the
bahamas
i've always i'm a sucker for the bahamas
go ahead mike
what's it like that nice oh today's a
beautiful day not a cloud in the sky
uh it's about uh 28 30 degrees
is the bahamas more than one place or is
it is it one island or more than one
oh so it's more than once lots of
islands
not much big population only about 400
000 people
sounds idyllic anyway what would you
like to do i live on you providence
island which is the biggest
oh yeah uh most populous island and is
that a u.s
territory oh no no we used to be um
a british colony do you remember
um edward
the uh the king who advocated oh he was
sent there that's right because he was a
collaborator
he was a collaborator with him yeah yeah
yeah so he uh he was sent there to be
governor general or something that's
right
i get all these uh barbados bahamas i
sometimes
get them mixed up and uh one of the
west uh indian islands has just uh
decided to become a republic to ask the
queen to leave
finally i think yes i think it's
barbados they're going to make her not
head of state
that's right yeah anyway i'm not a
bohemian citizen i'm um
us and uk dual national okay go ahead
mike
okay um last week i called about what
the republicans were doing
to disenfranchise voters and
um actually got some numbers there's
this senior writer for mother jones
harry biermann and he was on democracy
now and he's saying that
what the republicans are doing in
florida can affect up to 1.4
million voters which is pretty big
and then um also some other things
they're doing
the gop wants to require ballots to be
received by election day
instead of postmocked by election day
that's a big difference so if if you
have swords
i think i've certainly lost them i don't
know if you can still
hear them uh i can hear you chris but i
i lost mike is he's still there
yes mike what happened uh
i don't know it was a slight
interruption you were saying to me
i think the rest of the world heard you
uh that the republicans want
the ballot papers to be received by
election day not just
postmarked prior to election day go
ahead
yes and then they're also trying to keep
photo id
lords on the books and a lot of
minorities don't actually have photo ids
so that also skews the electorate um
and even in they're doing things like in
pennsylvania they're
trying to fight against uh dropbox is
being put in various places so people
can just deliver their ballots
so they're doing everything they can
just to keep the
electorate down because they know the
republicans will be favored by
a lower turnout that doesn't mean that
electoral fraud
isn't actually a real thing though mike
uh i can
testify to you uh that is every time
it's the republicans that are doing it
yeah you don't think democrats do
election fraud
well i don't think it's a serious
problem i mean i
i've been an expat for 22 years and i've
been voting by mail
for 22 years i mean my my ballot has a
barcode on it so they know where it's
from or who it's from
and it's a valid voter yeah we don't
have anything like that uh
protection i must say but i've fought
fought against a certain party often
enough in
inner cities to know that uh just
because you're supposedly the left wing
of the two parties
doesn't mean you can be trusted on
postal balloting mike thanks uh for that
malcolm is in spain on the lockdown
measures there
uh go ahead malcolm george nice to speak
to you the last time i spoke to you is a
few weeks ago and just
update me very quickly congratulations
on the door for your
birth of your
the scottish town of auburn yes exactly
from that today well yes
i agree now george i'm gonna i'm gonna
say something to you now and i want you
to think about it before you assassinate
me okay
okay okay and i'm gonna use in
like i won't use scottish football teams
because we know that rangers and celtic
up there and hearts and heads and
counting beef are down there but let me
let me put it in
in perspective and i know you don't like
china to be
to be slated at but here's one thing
it's a conspiracy theory which i know
you don't like okay
so let's imagine that covert 19 is
norwich city or
or cowden beach if you wanted to get in
football terms and you've got a real
madrid a liverpool and a manchester city
out there
now if they released on purpose
it was like against the trade deal with
america
and they're saying basically if you have
a go at us because i don't think we can
military
china can be anybody else at fighting
but
they can release a virus that can
the world and they really don't
give a monkeys about
it so i perhaps i say to you george
do you think that's a possibility that
they release are you phoning me
from a hospital malcolm
now george i knew you always you always
say to people
that you disagree with you sound mental
to me
first of all first of all the idea that
china that china can't fight anybody
when it has the biggest army in the
world and is bristling with
thermonuclear weapons is just about the
most mental statement
you could possibly make secondly george
so no i'll let you back in i want to
critique what you said
and explain why i think it's mental
explain why i think you must be on a day
out
from ward 5. if china
which whose economy was on track
to become the world's biggest economy
how could china possibly have an
economic interest in the collapse of
international trade when china is the
biggest
beneficiary of international trade
because it manufactures more than anyone
else malcolm
well on your first point um who's
who's faring very well at the moment
china who doesn't give a monkeys about
their populists and hong kong protests
and the rohingya you know like
that the muslims that they they are in
burma malcolm
they're in burma they are massacred in
burma
and have fled to bangladesh as refugees
those that manage to get out alive
anyway okay my point is
a little knowledge is dangerous and
that's what you've got
a little knowledge would you agree that
the
the chinese put the muslims
incarceration camps yes or no
absolutely not it's an absolute lie
are you serious
are you serious it's you that's escaped
from ward 5 if you don't believe that
china aren't locking up muslims in in
concentration camps you're on you you've
escaped from ward 5.
malcolm what's your evidence for that
um have you ever seen the pictures of
them being shipped off no
no they turned out to be pictures of
completely different people
in a completely different part of china
you really need to keep up malcolm
i asked you what your evidence was and
all you could say was
um have you not seen the pictures
well that's the thing well that's why i
listen to you george because i respect
your opinion on world events
you're not listening closely enough
first of all you say
first of all you say china can't fight
anybody
it is the world's biggest army
it has nuclear weapons by the
thousands but i can't fight for anybody
okay george so my point is that if you
go to war
on nuclear weapons everybody's dead
china are brutal enough to release a
virus for their own means i like
that's what i'm asking you what did they
gain what could they possibly have
gained
from a virus devastating the capitalist
economies
that were buying chinese goods by the by
the ocean lord
how could china benefit from that
george you need to wake up i'll tell you
how the benefit is trump does not get
reelected
biden gets in he's a he's a communist
china loving person now i know you're in
ward 5.
no no now i know that malcolm in spain
is actually calling uh from
ward 5 in broadmoor
joe biden is a communist
according to malcolm in spain let's hear
from joshua
in london go ahead joshua you're right
george yeah have i been going
good yeah i was just gonna um
i've been looking through and i don't
hate wikipedia at that gospel word
misunderstand me don't so do do correct
me if i'm wrong about any of this
i've looked at the turnout for scottish
parliament
elections okay like the turnout about 55
i think yeah yeah well the the maximum
they've ever got is about 58.6
okay that is the highest they ever have
had admittedly they haven't had that
many
the first one was only in i think 1999
and they've had about
what was it four or five six maybe six
maybe yeah
um yeah maybe i should have kept a
better count ain't that many but
the turnout for the scottish
independence referendum was eighty four
point seven percent yeah
well yeah yeah absolute record
yeah so how how can a tur a minute by
traditionally minimum turnout and it's
likely to be that
in the 2021 scottish parliament election
due due largely to covid it's probably
not going to be very high because people
are not going to be clearing at polling
stations
like they would be traditionally like
without you know minus covid how is that
sort of um well it's not a mandate
of course uh only uh a zealot uh could
possibly imagine
that it was a mandate we had
a once in a generation sometimes they
called it a once in a lifetime
referendum uh yes or no
asking these scottish people if they
wanted to
leave or stay but the dichotomy was yes
and no
and the nationalists were fighting for
the yes
and despite all of the prevailing
conditions
being in their favor the year
the 700th anniversary of braveheart
and and robert the bruce the battle
of bannockburn the question yes
no rather than leave remain
the franchise only people
living in scotland aged
16 or over were allowed to vote so the
captain of the
scotland football team wasn't allowed to
vote
because of course he's playing for
liverpool or manchester united or
arsenal or tottenham and living in
london so he didn't get a vote but the
captain of the
lithuanian football team who was briefly
living in scotland he did get a vote
16 year olds were allowed to vote while
the
voting age for all other elections is
18.
despite all of the prevailing conditions
being in the
favor of the separatists who wish to
partition
this small island they lost
on an 85 turnout
by 55 to 45
so my view is simple you said it was
going to be
once in a generation that's the very
least
that it can be once in a generation
six years is not a generation
even for domestic rabbits let's go to
the news
with jamie lowe curious about our
curriculum
have something to say then call us now
to join the debate on the mother of all
talk shows with george galloway
radio sputnik we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news clovid restrictions
in england will get tougher if rules are
not followed britain's health secretary
has warned
as the government introduces ten
thousand pound fines for people who fail
to self-isolate
matt hancock said the country was facing
a tipping point
if everyone follows the rules then we
can avoid a further national lockdown he
said
the prime minister boris johnson is
understood to be considering a ban on
households mixing
and reducing opening hours for pubs
asked if england could face another
national lockdown hancock said
i don't rule it out i don't want to see
it the move
under consideration by johnson could
take the form of a two-week mini
lockdown in england
being referred to as a circuit breaker
in an aim to stem a recent surge in
cases
on saturday a further 4422
new covered 19 cases and 27 deaths were
reported in the uk
visitors have flocked to blackpool
despite police warning against having a
last blast in the resort before tighter
restrictions come into force
people reported cues for attractions
heavy traffic and little social
distancing
and few people wearing masks indoors
lancashire will be subject to title
restrictions from tuesday
after significant increases in covert 19
cases but blackpool is exempt
police had said they were preparing for
large crowds over the weekend
singapore is distributing thousands of
devices that can track where a person
has been
and who they've interacted with the
small bluetooth device is meant for
those who do not own smartphones and
cannot use a contact tracing app that
was previously rolled out by the
singapore government
while there are some concerns over data
protection authorities say
the token helps vulnerable groups feel
safer when out and about
australia looks set to record its lowest
daily coronavirus increase for three
months with just 18 new cases reported
so far
the state of victoria the epicentre of
the country's covert 19 outbreak
recorded 14 new infections to sunday
morning down from 21
the day before new south wales and
queensland reported two cases each
the remaining states are yet to report
their figures but rarely record any new
cases
figures were last this low on june 23rd
victoria's premiere daniel andrews said
the numbers were caused for great
optimism
his state which is accounted for 75
percent of australia's 26
900 cases and 90 of its 849 deaths
has been under lockdown since early july
melbourne the state capital has been
under tighter restrictions than any
other areas
including a curfew and stay-at-home
orders anti-lockdown protests in the
city have become a regular site
earlier today demonstrators gathered in
the central business district
saturday's protests in the park saw
protesters being dispersed
by police on horseback just one in 10 of
the world's population is likely to be
protected against covert 19 and the
first year of vaccine being made
available according to scientists
analysts of global manufacturing
capacity shows just 2 billion doses
could be made in 2021
even if a vaccine was given the green
light by safety regulators at the start
of the year
but with seven of the nine prototype
vaccines in late stage clinical trials
requiring two doses
that's likely to be enough to immunise
only a little over 12 percent
of the 7.8 billion people who need it us
president donald trump has said he will
this week
nominate a woman to replace the late
supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg
escalating a political route over her
successor
ginsburg who was 87 died on friday just
under two months before the u.s
elections
trump's democratic rival joe biden
insists the decision on her replacement
should wait until after the vote
the ideological balance of the
nine-member court is crucial to its
rulings
on the most important issues in u.s law
trump has vowed to swear in ginsburg's
successor without delay
a move that's infuriated democrats who
fear republicans will vote to lock in a
decades-long conservative majority
on the country's highest court ginsburg
had also made her feelings clear in the
days before her death
my fervent wish is that i will not be
replaced until a new president is
installed she wrote in a statement to
her granddaughter
a package containing rice and poison
that was addressed to president donald
trump
has been intercepted before it reached
the white house the letter was
discovered as a screening facility for
white house mail earlier this week
officials said
they said a substance found inside the
envelope was identified as ricin
a poison found naturally in caster beans
the trump administration is yet to
comment on the reports
airstrikes on a taliban base in
northeastern afghanistan have killed at
least a dozen civilians
the twin afghan strikes incandesce come
as the country's government and the
taliban hold talks to reach a peace
settlement
provincial officials at a taliban
spokesperson said at least 12 civilians
were killed
and more than 10 injured a defense
ministry spokesperson claimed that more
than 40 taliban fighters were also
killed in the strikes the taliban
however did not confirm whether there
were any casualties amongst its fighters
and finally a football match was
disrupted by an unusual pitch invader
when an alpaca bounded onto the field
carlton athletics tie against ilkley
town in west yorkshire on saturday was
halted for 15 minutes when oscar the
alpaca
escaped from a nearby farm and joined
the action attempts were made to entice
it off the pitch with food before a farm
managed to shepherd it home
carlton is renowned in the league for
having alpacas nearby
ilkey manager simon armstrong said after
35 minutes it escaped came through the
entrance and proceeded to get on the
pitch
the referee stopped the game carlton
athletics said farm animals had been
kept near the pitch for several years
but it was the first time one had
managed to stop a match club chairman
john flynn
said i don't know how he got out there
must be a little gap in the barrier
somewhere as we've seen some chickens
here as well
oscar alpaca is reportedly very
inquisitive and appeared to be enjoying
himself
running up and down the pitch a couple
of players even said
he should be the man of the match and
that's the latest here on sputnik news
i'm jamie lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now here's the second poll assuming
because i know we're not going to buy
the russian vaccine
because that would be too much to bear
i'm getting it but you won't be offered
it
who should get any vaccine that we
do produce who should get up first
a health staff b the old
and infirm c by lottery
this will short the sheep from the butch
this will show the malthusians
answer that one who should get up first
health staff
the old indian firm or by lottery you
can vote
on my twitter feed now i did start off
by saying and you'll have seen that i
won't be in this studio with anyone else
without my mask on
i've got it off now because i'm alone in
the uh
studio uh ranjit broad doctor
physician surgeon has helped us through
this
crisis and we're sticking with him but
he even he must be getting
anxious as these numbers begin to
mount let's see if i'm right dr ranjit
thank you
again for joining us numbers are pretty
bleak are they
george good to be back with you um yes
george there's no there's no question
that um
uh the much feared second wave
essentially is
upon us and upon us um across europe
probably
um as we saw italy showing
uh being ahead of the us by about three
weeks
um in february march april period
we can probably see that spain is about
six weeks ahead of us and france about
three weeks ahead of us
but we are very much following the
trajectory of their rise in numbers of
infections yesterday we had
test proven uh four and a half thousand
infections it seems likely now that
there are 70 or 80
000 people who currently are infected in
britain
um those rates have doubled over the
period of a week and that's seen in a
lot of other indices as well
so the rates of hospitalization are
starting to increase
um our rates of hospitalization
again essentially doubled uh our death
rates uh
have essentially doubled they were you
know for
three or four weeks they've been quite
low over the last past the summer
they were actually if you total them up
and look back in retrospect
there were probably no days when there
were zero deaths
and the weekly average was running
between 50 and
70. that doubled over the last week and
sadly we've had 136 people who have died
of coronavirus not with it of
coronavirus
over the last week so all of these
numbers are doubling
um and probably we're having as i say
four and a half thousand cases a day
but it's the rate of increase that is
most worrying
and there's kind of many sources and
many
uh data um measures
are showing essentially that within a
couple of weeks time
we could be uh back into
a similar situation uh as in march
um on a rising exponentially rising
number of cases george now uh the
evidence that i have seen
from europe which as you say is ahead
of us as they were in the beginning uh
it hit there before it hit here
more fool asked for not taking the
breathing space that we were thus
offered
to get ourselves in better shape to
deal with this but there's some evidence
isn't there
that though cases are rising
rapidly on the european continent
that death rates are not following them
there is some evidence therefore
that this second wave is less fatal less
deadly than the first wave
we must hope and pray that that is true
of course
first of all is it in your view likely
to be true and secondly
what if it isn't what if we are back
to a thousand people a day
dying uh of coronavirus how are we going
to cope with that
i think that those both reasonable
questions george and um
uh you know as i was saying i don't
think there's a fundamental difference
between the virus but i think that the
way that our countries have
um reorganized to cope with the virus
has
changed significantly obviously you know
the first time around
we had virtually no ability to test
and that had to be ramped up from zero
all over the place some countries did
that very effectively some
very uh poorly um
it's true that a certain the most
perhaps the most vulnerable section of
the society
um has caught the virus and so
we're likely to have slightly uh more
resilient
population overall however there are
still very many
millions who have not had the virus who
are susceptible so there's certainly
this pandemic has a long way to run if
left unchecked
of course it's not being totally left
unchecked we do have tracing we do have
tracking and um other countries have
shown it's possible both to
you know get on top of the first wave
and get on top of the second wave the
ones who did it very successfully the
first time around
we've talked about before um the korean
peninsula did extremely well china did
extremely well
other countries like new zealand did
extremely well um
china essentially eradicated the virus
and has returned to normal and shows no
sign of an appreciable second wave
having
had a high level of vigilance through
very good well-coordinated public
testing measures and social isolation
um on this second wave countries like
japan germany
again south korea have done well at
essentially getting on top of the virus
early and therefore minimizing its
impact
on us all um you know un
unfortunately um all the evidence so far
is that our testing and tracing program
remains very poor the numbers
are much higher but the numbers of
people who are tested
is about half the number of tests
performed
and some people are getting two tests
yeah
that's right they're double counting in
in many respects sometimes
swap still being taken from the nose and
the mouth and the counters two tests so
all of these um things can confound the
numbers
slightly equally uh in particular our
our tracing system we've talked about
many times as you know uh dido harding
who is
a former chief executive talk talk group
a dame and very connected to our current
administration and and
this very establishment figure has been
put in charge of this without any
appreciable
um acumen in this in this department or
any particular qualifications
all of the money which is being pumped
into this increasing amount of money
which is being pumped into this field
is not being run via the nhs it's not
the nhs
capacity which has been expanded to deal
with all of these medical problems
rather
the ax has continued to be wielded on
the nhs and all of this money is being
pushed
privately into group 4 securities serco
the big four
market accountancy groups all of these
um and other private providers uh the
lighthouse laboratories famously for the
testing and they're
very large centers so it's not the local
expertise of the national health service
which is being
increased in capacity and increased in
funding rather it continues to be
starved of resources
more and more money is going into a
private sector who are not performing
adequately
and we know that probably only a fifth
of the people who are being
contacted perhaps half of the people who
um
have a positive test uh half of those
contacts are traced
and we know of those half who are traced
only a fifth are actually self-isolating
largely because many of them are uh are
unable economically
to stellar that that that brings me on
to
in a way my main question to you now uh
according to boris johnson people who
are told
to self-isolate are going to be
fined up to 10 000 pounds
if they don't do it um first of all how
we're going to know
that they didn't do it who's in charge
of
finding out that they didn't do it and
is
ten thousand pounds a realistic amount
of money to
find someone who's broken their
quarantine
because they desperately had to go to
work
because they can't live uh on the
current uh stipend that they have
well i think all of those points are are
absolutely spot on
no one is going to be able to uh find
the vast majority of people who are
unable to
uh self-isolate um there's no social
provision there's no
monetary position there's no place that
is given to them where they can isolate
from society
that was why i had to say the same thing
again and again that was why china was
able to eradicate the virus
after about 80 000 cases and they had
less than
half of 100th of one percent of their
population
have had the virus um because they
provided social support they provided
social isolation from where social place
with the population of a positive could
isolate from there they could be nursed
back to health
and after several tests discharged back
into the community or
if they deteriorated could rapidly
access good
you know gold standard healthcare
including ventilation or whatever
medications are available
um so those measures are not in place
we've given a huge amount of money to
a private sector who are unable to carry
on with their normal private practice
just essentially to keep their doors
open
without them providing any service we
haven't used even those private
hospitals to put
people who for example have tested
positive and need isolation
in a place where they can get adequate
medical and social care so
no we won't they won't be able to do so
you know
the concept that now an app will be
launched and that everyone will get on
it
if their reward is going to be a 10 000
pound fine when they're unable to follow
the advice because there's no actual
provision made for them
you know you can see why these measures
are as ineffective in our society
and why british and american society
in the laissez-faire free market
fundamentalist economic model
generating so much wealth from so much
of the world having
taken money and over fists from so much
of the world is still able to
unable to provide for such a large
proportion
of our own populations and why the
indices of social deprivation in our
countries are spiraling out of control
now george
lastly and i'm grateful for your time as
always
where do we stand on vaccine
am i right in assuming that we will not
be buying
the russian vaccine even though uh it
is uh on the face of it a success story
uh many other countries are asking for
it and being given it
uh i'm presuming we won't because
uh britain hates russia and america
hates russia
and america hates china they hate both
so do we so
our own i say our own loosely it'll be
owned by a multinational drug company
our own vaccine when is it happening
a very good question george of course um
i don't i'm sure you don't
hate the russian or chinese people on
the country have a greater
admiration and respect uh you could even
say love of the
of the great things that these nations
as as other
nations have given to the world um
and i'm sure even our own government
wouldn't put it crudely
in that way but essentially you're right
they have a deep
enmity and geopolitical rivalry both the
british government
and the american government is
dominating the american election
whether they emphasize you know when
trump was asked questions recently
um about russian interference he even
said you know
it's china you've got to be worrying
about at the moment so
they they've conflicted themselves as to
who is the biggest bogeyman who is their
biggest
rival whether they look militarily or
economically in terms of it's being
economic powerhouse probably china
but in terms of its nuclear arsenal and
military capability
it's russia and of course the two are
now very closely aligned in
opposing the interventionism and
aggressive
nature of u.s and british military
presence in their in their regions and
in the world and their economically
uh economic strategy so yes i think it's
in a highly unlikely um that
this uh vaccine which has been shown to
be safe
but it's basically going through an
extended phase through trial of a large
part of the population in russia
elsewhere which has been um
essentially promised in uh in millions
and hundreds of millions of doses to
different countries around the world
our own country which has brought up um
you know hundreds of millions of doses
from very many
companies has shown no interest in
acquiring that
vaccine though it is proved as
efficacious and more efficacious than
others and has been the first to grant
license but
people you know justly say it's been
grant granted license
during the period of its phase 3 trial
essentially
it's showing excellent data all the data
that we have and i've reviewed that the
paper in the lancet uh shows that it's
extremely efficacious and safe
of course when you're giving something
in hundreds of millions of doses you
need to have very robust safety data
because even a very small element of
being unsafe
can translate into disastrous
consequences
so this is a you know a reasonable
criticism which is held up however
it is unreasonable that there will be no
interest shown in this
um vaccine which so far has proven to be
one of the
amongst the best candidates in the world
and yes it is being rolled out
um in russia and other countries the
chinese also have a vaccine which
they're rolling out to
certain groups high-risk groups and
within their military
in their own country um and these are
the front runners so the front runners
are from
the geopolitical block which is our
rival and it's unquestionably the case
that we will be denied
access to those uh at least in the first
instance that the main
um uh vaccines that we're backing at the
glaxosmithkline
oxford vaccine uh which was temporarily
halted due to safety concerns but it
only lasted about a week and has been
that trial is ongoing um and uh
america's so-called warp speed uh
program
from uh uh from from their a major
pharmaceutical company so those um uh
vaccines
trials are ongoing licenses are not
expected to be granted this year
um so it's going to be a long gonna be a
long cold winter then
for the coronavirus i think that's right
and i think
we're essentially in the same situation
where we are left with the tried and
tested public health measures as our
only measure
to combat this and it's uh you know it's
it's it's failure
to implement adequate health measures
of our government and the united states
government is what's leaving us in this
ongoing
situation and i do understand there's a
degree of skepticism
there's a degree of fatigue with this
question there's a degree of hostility
to the government which translates into
a disbelief in the pre the very
existence of this virus the virus is
real
the threat is real i'm afraid the curve
is increasing and we are going to see a
second wave
and what we should remember is the it's
the inadequacy
of our government to institute adequate
health measures which is leaving us
in this situation where possibly our
liberties will be increasingly
infringement of 13 million people are
already
under some form of partial lockdown and
it increasingly looks the case that it's
being signaled
that there'll be an increasing lockdown
perhaps over the the half-term bank
holiday
certainly we're expecting the peak of
this um by
by the end of october and november
period george
dr angie thanks as always on the
coronavirus we never really get on to
other
health matters because of the gravity
of the situation dan works with me
here through the glass you can you can
see him but he's got a mask on on me i
put mine on
uh also because the russians are very
strict about
these uh protocols can you still hear me
i hope you can still hear me
dan has with some of his
friends one of whom is me
has launched a demand for a coronavirus
tax
on the very wealthiest people in the
country
what's not to love about that dan
thanks for uh agreeing to stay a few
minutes
um tell people why we should have such a
tax
who it would be on and what sort of
money it would yield and what we could
do with that money
well this tax is very specifically aimed
at the very wealthy
and they only represent actually a tiny
proportion of the population we're
saying
anyone with a personal fortune of 10
million or over
10 million yeah that's only so even most
lottery winners wouldn't
have to pay this tax exactly and you
know that's
some 20 000 people in the uk um that
have a wealth of over
10 million and we're saying a wealth tax
not on income tax
uh we're proposing this as a one-off
wealth tax
and that would generate somewhere in the
region between if you take
the very lowest thresholds as a minimum
of
uh some fifteen thousand people that
have over ten billion and then
an even smaller minority about four and
a half thousand that have over 80
million pounds in personal wealth
that would generate well over 17 billion
probably in the region of 25 billion if
you just take the minimum thresholds of
those two figures that would be
five percent one-off tax on people
who have a personal fortune of
between 10
million pounds and what so
over over 10 million pounds is the is
the blanket
everybody over who's worth over uh 10
million pounds
would have to pay the 5 one-off corona
virus tax
exactly and you know that would seems
reasonable to me
can could anyone dispute that well if
you won 10 million on the lottery would
you really be
that upset to give 500 000 pounds to
make
you know your community in the country a
little bit better well exactly better
support the nhs yeah
that's what we're putting and this money
would go into public health
well is that your plan we think this
should be spent on public health
infrastructure
jobs i mean we're looking at now uh
official unemployment figures
creeping up to three million and that's
not including people that are
struggling in part-time work not able to
find enough work
and even people that are working
suffering from in-work poverty so we
think this should be used to
support our nhs support infrastructure
support the creation of jobs
and this would you know move some of
that capital that's not doing anything
at the moment
it's all locked up in yeah i mean
they're doing what are they doing
with that five percent anyway if they
they've got 10 million
they're not gonna miss five percent of
it as a one-off
and where is it anyway it's sitting in a
bank or in property or in
jewelry or bitcoin or wherever they've
got it it's mind-boggling i mean there's
only
you know a certain amount you need to
live on and
you know how much ever you can spend on
luxuries and
you know how many super yachts and
private jets you know do people need
and this this country is really
struggling at the moment how do people
uh uh support this campaign i'm fully
behind it myself
well they can go to coronatex.org or
look up workerspartybritain.org
so we're campaigning for the labour
party actually to adopt this position
you're demanding sarkir starmar uh
demanded of the government well that's
not because you thought there was no
point in going directly to the
government
or because you've got a lot of
confidence in serkio starman
well uh they're meant to be the
opposition so
you know we really want to say the
opposition
should put forward you know the
interests of the people
have at heart and over 61 of people
apparently support
the idea of a wealth tax so i'd be
embarrassed personally to call myself
a member of the party if they didn't
support this policy
very interesting a one-off five percent
coronavirus tax on people worth
more than 10 million pounds
actually if i was worth over 10 million
pounds i'd be embarrassed to
uh oppose it i'd write you the check
for the five percent dan thanks uh very
much
uh for that uh the coronavirus
tax campaign sounds like a good one to
me who should get the vaccine first
health staff
47 the old and the infirm
47 by lottery just six percent
well done you well done uh you who
reject
the idea of malthus you can vote now
on my twitter feed at george galloway
you can call in now
if you want to talk about the vaccine
and who should get it i'll remind you of
the number
oh two or seven seven nine eight two two
five five
or if you're in the u.s zero zero one
seven
five seven seven four four four four
eight zero let me take a sixty second
break
[Music]
tune in every thursday to loud and clear
with brian becker for a regular segment
called
criminal injustice about the most
egregious conduct of our courts
and how justice is denied to so many
people in this country
tune in to loud and clear this thursday
and every thursday for thorough and
independent analysis of our criminal
injustice system
well um how did i do i'm sorry prime
minister
at no point did you drive on the
left-hand side of the road
and instead of driving us forward you
made several
u-turns we haven't gone anywhere
i think you'll find if you turn
backwards uh enough times
eventually you'll go forward so yeah
did i pass no you failed
miserably but my teachers said i'd get
much higher grades
better look next time this doesn't
happen to people
like me you leave
me no choice
i'm sorry but rules are rules even for
prime ministers
what on earth is that my
mutant pets
dominate cummins no big
algorithm get it
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
[Music]
no health staff 45 that's uh
what who people think should get the
vaccine first i'd vote for the health
staff because then we
have them in place to treat the rest of
us but that's down to
b is the old and infirm 47
and by lottery is up two to
eight percent uh jason in kidderminster
is on the line let's hear from him jason
hello george how's it going all good by
the grace of god thank you go ahead
yeah well before i make my main point i
just want to say that
the rule of six there is an exception if
you've heard
for people who shoot grouse
which is absolutely i'm not making this
up it's
honestly true but there's an exception
to the group of six for people who shoot
grouse
you got honest to god all right how many
are they allowed to gathering i'm not
sure i think it might be 30 but i'm not
sure why can't six men shoot grouse
just as effectively as 16. i imagine
it's because
i think something to do with the
environment maybe they need the peasants
that go beating
beating the ground to make the grouse
rise maybe they'd have to beat the
ground themselves and we couldn't have
that
my main point really is basically my
cousin
her girlfriend was tested for the corona
virus
and uh and she was positive and then she
went back home and and basically i think
there's a massive flaw
in the system because what it's saying
here and i'm on the nhs website it says
that if you live with someone who is
tested positive
then you should then self-isolate for 14
days
but the problem is it literally doesn't
explicitly say that all those people
should get a test
and it also says that the person is
tested positive
should stay away from the rest of the
household so the floor
i think is if say someone in my
household's tested positive
then i could get catch the virus off
those
five days later for example
and then but like then i would have to
self-isolate
you see where i'm going yeah i do yeah
yeah
i think it's actually a massive flaw
because really
what should happen is you should have a
test say
two days before the end of your 14-day
isolation
because what they're doing is if one
person in your house tests positive
they're assuming that every single
person in that house has got it
and as we know the majority of people
are asymptomatic
so that you could get it off someone in
your household five days after they've
tested positive
you know and then and then you're going
out you know
it's not half a shambles jason thanks
for the
the call now uh back by popular demand
and i mean popular demand on faith on
youtube
it's chris in colchester who's got a new
theory chris
welcome back i'm not that popular am i
yeah you people have been demanding you
all night
well you've got a fan club
they're not then they're not my theory
so are they they
they come from uh from epidemiologists
like
cole hennigan and sinatra gupta so
natural gupta was on bbc
question time this week yeah i mean you
were saying she was she couldn't get on
the mainstream media but i was
just going to make that point to you uh
which you've done prophylactically
yourself
she was on bbc question time yeah but
she can't get on your show
no but she got on bbc question time
which is admittedly a much smaller
audience
uh but yes we'll get around chris well
good for the bbc i mean andrew marr tore
matthew hancock to the pieces this
morning that sounds unlikely to me
andrew has never typically never torn
anyone to
pieces well it's not difficult to turn
matthew hancock he's a lion imbecile
and you know he ties himself in pieces
but
um we've seen this weekend there's been
reports that
one third of covert deaths in july and
august
uh were caused from other illnesses um
and and like i said last in july and
august
yep where was that reported chris
uh the telegraph the mail
okay go on and uh and the test like i
said last week we're
we're relying on these tests these pcr
tests that um
uh they're quite unreliable uh there's
very sensitive picking up the dead virus
so we have what else can we do but rely
on the test
well i don't think we should be doing
math testing um
no i don't i don't you support the you
support the health immunity don't you
well it's been heard immunity's been
given a dirty name because of
because because of malthus
because of because of dominic cummings
no thomas malthus who
basically said let the devil take the
hindmost we've got too many people
anyway
too many old people yeah too much of a
boredom
well no but uh but that's not obviously
not my view is it i want to protect the
elderly
and um that that is the view of sinatra
gupta as well uh
anyway you said you had a new theory
tell me your new theory
well these are my theories i didn't have
a new
i don't know i don't have these theories
it's not it's not me coming up with
theories it's
people uh you know dr
braary's coming up with theories that
there's going to be a second wave carl
said there's no well to be fair he is a
surgeon and a doctor
and he is uh giving us the facts
that thousands of people a day
are now testing positive for coronavirus
uh dead people are doubling a
hospitalized people are doubling
number of people on ventilators has
troubled
uh this is not a theory this is a fact
chris
yeah but you don't have to act you act
like everything he's saying he's coming
live from the mount sinai like he
broadcast it from there you can
challenge what he says
carl hennigan is far more qualified than
doctor brock he's a top ever dangerous
is he saying that these people are not
in hospital no that they're not dying no
no of course not no of course not but
there's more people dying from flu in
the last few months
that's on top of the virus all these
other things are killing people on top
of the coronavirus
well the lockdown deaths the most of it
lockdown is going to kill more people
than coronavirus
well you're on a better point there uh
chris uh you're definitely on a better
point there
anyway you're back by public demand
philippine leeds
is also eagerly anticipated go ahead
phillip
hello george nice to be on thank you
what's your theory you've got a theory
my oh my my theory is a deep dark and
suspicious theory
i'm not a cynic by nature but i've been
dragged into cynicism
with them by the romances it happens
it's happened to me a few times in my
life
it's right i mean i mean look i think we
need to disabuse ourselves of this sort
of naive belief
that and the government's priority
is everybody's well-being i'm not for a
moment suggesting that the opposite is
the case but i think we need to look at
sure but actually yeah well i wouldn't
send this government
out for a loaf never mind to look after
my public health
i wasn't trusting the price for loaf
george um
the problem is people reveal themselves
better by their character
by their church they review their
character by their choices and actions
and
i was looking at the way they farmed the
testing out to these you know
sort of crony capitalists private
companies they didn't ask the nhs
who might actually know what they were
doing they didn't ask the military who
are used to doing big
sudden projects and getting it right
nine times out of ten
and and the net results what's happening
is the numbers are spiking
this is not getting better and the
country's getting dragged further and
further
into recession now the part that's
making me cynical
is people like myself and probably you
george
understand that recession is in fact a
huge opportunity for the wealthy
well for some sections yeah yeah
and people with money when things get
done you can snap off your property
and you can even buy assets and so on of
course i get that yeah
and and and and look people have the
money to buy at the bottom of the market
making
profits at the top of the market yeah
and i i'm i'm not i'm not trying to be
ultra cynical about this but i
i do think that there are benefits for
a certain sections for a certain section
but not not for the ruling
elite as a whole uh not for capitalism
as a whole uh the big losers on assets
crashing
and being picked up at the bottom of the
market are themselves capitalists
uh uh abs absolutely and i i think i
think they're the entrepreneurial
capitalists what you see
is the layer above them with people who
have sort of family money
and i don't want to use names people
like for example david cameron who was
family money i'm not suggesting he's
done anything improper
but people people of that hill i'm
suggesting he's done
lots of things improper in fact he's a
complete
scoundrel phillip you're not
cynical enough i'm i'm so glad that you
said it
i i i didn't have to um but but i think
there's people of that class will do
very well
if the people who invest the people who
don't get their hands dirty
um who have money to invest and who
trade in people's lives
and who trade in property i agree with
you entrepreneurs people who actually
make things
they'll suffer very badly as well yeah
it's about time
they stood up for themselves a bit more
robustly uh before they uh end up uh
on the bread line like uh so many uh
already are
and it's likely to get much worse philip
that was a terrific call
uh don't be a stranger keep calling back
won't you i need to take one last
60-second break
johnny how you can love
[Music]
stop banging on the toilet door amber
stop banging on the toilet door
you're gonna fry in the pilot anyway
i'll uh
i'll talk to you when we land
although that could take a considerable
amount of time
johnny
breaking news expert analysis and
exclusive stories
all in one place
radio sputnik telling the untold
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
now in response to the poll trudy says
no one should get the vaccine
as it may be unsafe as it's not being
tested enough
and there's no legal comeback if you get
ill from it
and georgie says a very tricky question
i devised it that way initially i
thought elderly in the infirm but
i voted for health care workers not to
selfishly protect myself
as one but to ensure we're about to look
after
to ensure that we are about to look
everyone else if we shield vulnerable
people properly
undertake functional track and trace
that group
may escape covet ah
if as bill clinton would put it it
depends
what you mean by if stuart
in rougely wants to talk about china
i'm always up for that stuart go ahead
sir hello uh george pleased to speak to
you i've always been a big admirer
all day i'm not getting this loud and
clear as everyone else
i'm sorry go on john that's better
okay sorry yeah i'd say i've always been
a great admirer of yours but i don't
think you will be after after what i've
got to say
um can i can i just say that we we brits
actually don't hate
china or russia but we do hate their
governments
why do you hate them what have they ever
done to you stewart
the russian russian people haven't done
anything to me
they were absolutely stirring in the war
and we couldn't
win the war without them uh but the
thing is what we do
is we hate dictators we hate the
characters
like putin taking care is he a dictator
how is stewart how is he a dictator
he's a dictator because he's just
manipulated the law
so that he can be re uh re-elected
but he'd only be re-elected whatever you
want but straight on
i'll let you back in i just want to
point out a rather obvious flaw in what
you're saying
he could only be re-elected if the
majority of people
voted for him and if they voted for him
he wouldn't be
a dictator yes yes and i appreciate the
point and you're absolutely right
however he's manipulated the law
so that he can have himself put in a
place for re-election
how long a british prime minister can be
re-elected
for 50 years for the rest of their life
as long as they get re-elected no no
no george no george his party can be
re-elected on a manifesto
you can change prime ministers as many
times as you like you can and you
probably
my point to you stuart is there are no
term limits
to how long you can be the prime
minister of britain
and there's certainly no time limits as
her majesty is proving
for how long you can be the head of
state in britain
yeah but she was born into the job
that's the difference she wasn't
sure you're not seriously
saying she was born into the job that's
different
right that we think is different it is
how is it different
oh i can't let you away how is it
different
she had no choice beauty manipulation we
have no
choice we have no choice she's the head
of state
whether we like it or not putin is the
elected
president yes yes and he wasn't he was
but the point is they had a law that
said you could only do so many terms
and then they had a reference well
because they had a referendum to
scrap that but the point i'm making to
you we
don't have an elected head of state and
neither do we have
term limits on how long you can be the
prime minister for
so neither of those two complaints of
yours
make him a dictator
well again again with these kleptocracy
mates who
that's a different matter i'm against
kleptocracy
there's quite a few kleptocrats just
along the road from me here
you don't need to be a russian to be a
kleptocrat stewart
i knew you were going to say that
because i i thought i'm surprised you
didn't say boris and carla
but as well i'd like to mention i need
to let you go now because of the hour
stuart tell me this where is rougely
rosie is right in the middle of
staffordshire
it it's about eight miles from canick
mitchfield
excellent and stafford that's right in
the middle
we used to have a power station yeah
good man um you've
uh educated me tonight on that at least
john
is in benidorm now i'm not going to say
i wish
i'm not going to say i wish i was in
benidorm because that would be
untrue but i'm very glad to hear from
you
yeah betty dorms uh divided into
two areas the civilized area
and the nazis civilized there tell me is
it the british that live in the
civilized area
no i do and so quite a few bridges do
but it's mainly spanish the holiday
flats
what they use for between four and eight
weeks a year and they're empty for the
rest of the year now you were poorly the
last time i spoke you were in the
hospital
are you better now yeah i had corvettes
and then i had a double heart um
jesus art operation which i got over and
i'm much better now
excellent very glad to hear first of all
i just like to comment on the health
situation in spain because it's worse
than england yeah it's ahead of us
two min two three weeks maybe yeah
uh at the end of july the spanish
government might you wear
masks everywhere on the streets
on transport in the shops everywhere you
go you've got to wear a mask doesn't
matter where you are
and since they've done that the spanish
corvette engines uh
have gone up the mouse in europe
so that hasn't worked the masses haven't
defense
it hasn't made any difference
well that's very very unfortunate
yeah well most of the spanish people in
betty dorm now have gone back to madrid
madrid has got the highest amount of
infection in there in europe and it
should be on the lockdown
it's the harbor under lockdown starting
monday
but if the figures don't improve it
should be under complete lockdown
and the whole spine will be under
lockdown before november
oh dear dear dear john stay safe i know
that uh
they've looked after you well there but
uh let's uh
try and keep you out of hospital uh if
we can
rashid is in long beach now there i'd
like to be
he wants to talk about donald trump go
ahead rasheed
hey george i just wanted to bring the
attention to your listeners about the
revelations uh from a recent book by bob
woodward about uh
a uh attempted soft coup by some of the
generals particularly uh
mr mad dog mattis who was secretary of
defense at the
out to be it time out to be not so mad
after all
well it could be uh not so mad don't
forget
that was same gentleman who led the
destruction of fallujah
where he had no
no reluctance to tie civilians on tanks
and
personnel carriers so protect american
troops yeah
so that's a kind of virtuous human being
that is
supposedly leading uh appointing these
types
uh when he well first of all they turn
against them
and are trying their best to destroy him
and secondly they stand for the precise
opposite of what he claimed
in the election campaign himself to
stand for
well he's uh you know i i couldn't tell
you the details because i'm not
into that but my speculation simply he's
such a total outsider
he he assumed the republican
establishment
represented main street when the
republican establishment represents
wall street and the military industrial
complex
and they're never going to let that cash
cow go away and to
be promoted whether you're in the
military whether you're the judiciary
whether you're in the legislature
you have to join that team anybody who's
not part of that team gets
pushed out yeah so you've read the
woodwork book were you impressed
by mr woodward's book yeah or by the
attempt
mr woodward's an insider his job is
political smash-up
so as needed he'll write dirt as needed
he'll write something positive
but i'm grateful that these revelations
on the internal macenace's the internal
interesting warfare is being spilled out
because the public never
sees this and never hears about it and
whether you're for
trump or against trump the fact that
there's an internal attempt to this
uh ignore the actions of elected
you know uh president should be
questionable i mean i
i'm pretty long in the tooth and i
remember the way they came after jimmy
carter
and i remember the way they came after
uh josh whitlam
in australia anybody who deviates from
the program has to be smashed yeah
and he someone may look like an insider
but if he's even one-tenth
out of their frame of reference he has
to go
just uh in in a sentence rasheed do you
think trump's going to be re-elected
uh you know uh george um i've
when i would look back at 2016 and being
participating in elections as an
observer since 1976
the vote rigging on the state level on
the national level is
absurd and in 2016 the democratic party
the u.s establishment thought hillary
had it in the bag
they took their foot off the accelerator
they're not going to let that happen
again but
if you go to the general population
outside of the east coast on the west
coast
he still has considerable support now
the question is can the vote rigging
overcome the considerable support if
it's close they can steal it
but if it's massive they have to do
their work to hide it rasheed thanks
as always for the call last call i
suspect is lee in grimsby
who has a theory for curing coronavirus
we better hear him
go ahead lee hello there yeah you could
call it a theory i suppose
um well it's about a rhetorical question
george
do you know anybody that's never got a
cold okay
right so the answer is no um which means
that this is probably endemic which
we're facing
um and therefore the only way around
this is we can't get a vaccine we've got
a vaccine for the flu but we all know
that doesn't work people still die from
the flow
so it does it does work it protects a
large number of people from the flu
protects to an extent okay i'll give you
that
but people still die the flu okay sure
but
okay so we've got to look at ways to get
around this and
uh a study came out we did a few studies
as you're probably aware of and
uh chicago medical uh producers three
the other day where they've looked at
people
with sufficient okay this is respect
retrospective so this is people who were
already deficient in vitamin d
who then caught the corvona coronavirus
and um struggled to uh to get over it so
there was a
you know a direct link between a lack of
vitamin d and
and the problem with the virus which
means heading into especially in england
places
where we're going to get very little sun
shortly uh a second wave is
i would say um almost certain certainty
at this point
so what i'm saying is people need to
stock up on vitamin d while it counts
that's a very good advice
it's very good advice lee i'm i'm
following it myself
uh i'm taking vitamin d supplement
uh i can't see i like it i actually feel
um although other people don't but i
actually feel a little bit sick after i
take the tablet just for
a minute or so until it passes
but i figure it's far better to take the
vitamin d
get as much vitamin d as you can from
the sunshine
take it it's over the counter it's not
particularly expensive
shop around you can get it quite
economically
take your vitamin d supplement
stay as far away from as many people as
you can
that much to me is obvious
if you don't get close enough to catch
the virus from someone else
then you'll be fine you might be
extremely unlucky and pick
up from a surface keep washing your hand
keep
using these sanitizers that are
everywhere
there are some people you can't stay
away from you can't
not kiss your wife you cannot not hug
your children
and i'm not going to stop doing that i'd
rather
die than do that
but as far as you can avoid close can
contact with as many people as you can
i wear a mask not because it's going to
stop me getting it but because it will
reduce
the chances of me giving it to someone
else
i'm selfless like that let's do
what we can and pray to the almighty
whom i believe in with all my heart
that this second wave is not as
devastating as the first one was
i know there's a lot of people out there
who don't trust the state
who don't trust the mass media don't
trust the political class
and i understand that because i don't
trust them
either i told you at the beginning about
this extraordinary book
written by the ordinary wife of a very
very ordinary member
of the political class and it is
a dismal read indeed i know why
the credibility of our rulers is so
reduced
but this is not a capitalist conspiracy
because for that to be true cuba would
have to be in on it
communist china would have to be in on
it
communist vietnam would have to be in on
and they're not it's real it's dangerous
may god go with you all and you stay
safe enough
to be back with me next week at the same
time
same place it's been marvelous
[Music]
you